Hello, everybody!
Me, Rem, here.
Hello, hello.
Hello, everyone.
It's Rem time.
All right, let me set up everything.
Okay, so apparently I should move myself so you guys can
actually see the map.
Let me do that real quick.
Wow!
Set the map?
Oh, my God!
Wow!
Yeah, stream snipe, stream snipe, I can finally see where
she's, what, what her team is.
What, I thought you were doing, oh, just stream, so who
cares?
If you're stream sniping me in this, you know, like, oh my
god.
If that's how it takes for you to win in bronze, that's sad.
If you really need a stream snipe, me, just to win the game,
that's really, really sad.
Just know who, what kind of Elo, you're stream sniping on,
if this is what you need to win, you're, you'll never get
better, you'll see stuck in that Elo, you need this to win,
you'll, I love you, sad, let me see, I gotta make sure,
like, um, like, it doesn't cover too much, There we go.
Also, apparently, I don't know.
I have like, I get like a hundred frames whenever I'm
streaming this game.
It's just my PC.
If I was on anyone else's PC, it'd be fine.
It's just me.
It's just my PC.
I don't know why.
I mean, it's literally, I don't know what's around my PC.
I get a hundred.
I don't notice it that much.
But I have a feeling my gameplay would improve a lot by
playing with my actual frames.
But it's like whenever... Oh, yeah.
Also, I forgot.
I play on high settings.
I need to change that.
Let me see.
What do I need to do?
Like, I feel like, do I just put it all on Medium?
I guess?
Do I just put it all on Medium?
Maybe this is why.
That might be why.
Oh, yeah.
I have the...
But when I don't stream it, it'll be, like, 200 frames if I
don't stream it.
Low everything?
Is Low everything the way to go for this game?
game how ugly would this game be how about effects turn off
shadows where the fuck is okay low um fog and shadow all
right how about post-process bloom area lights depth of
field uh keep textures high i'll put a medium yeah i was
gonna say how fucking shit would this game look
I don't think it was super chat.
Thank you.
My favorite break rem streamer.
Think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Kuka, think it was super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dude, I saw your last stream after work yesterday.
Who knew Kulin could lead to a skip rope jiggly game?
Maybe you can bring a scarlet back on your next productive.
Dude, yes, we'll all be productive.
But, all right.
Daddy's always like, he knows I need barks.
He'll get more food.
And I'm so tempted to teach him a lesson.
And I was like, fine, eat it all.
Eat it all.
later and can't do anything about it.
I'm gonna leave the I'm gonna leave the cat on the floor
just so he knows it's empty and that's the consequences of
of his actions.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna I'm gonna give him all his food.
I'm gonna give him dinner and then I'll leave the cat on the
floor and I know he won't learn from it.
He's not gonna learn anything.
He's just gonna
I'm gonna give him all the food and leave the cat open so he
knows it's empty it's for his own good I know he's not gonna
learn I know he's not gonna take any lesson from this he's
just like yay early food I
left the cat I left the cat on the floor we'll see if he
figures it out that's future dad's problem he will not grow
as a person
Let's see, Mr. BrokenBot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I feel that mindset Toki couldn't go through it on rivals.
No one has any brain cells left.
It felt like, I don't know if this is true, but I saw
someone on Twitter.
I don't remember who it was.
I was like, doom scrolling destroys short-term memory.
And I'm like, oh, fuck.
That makes no more.
It's over.
There's no salvaging this.
It would doom scrolling feels so good.
It's over.
There's no salvaging whatever's left in there.
It's like there's no there's nothing that can fix that.
There's nothing Nothing it's already too late like no
therapy or Support group can fix doom scrolling.
Imagine there's a doom scrolling support group I'll relapse
you can't there you can't put me in rehab.
I'll be there.
I'll break out.
I will doom scroll We're so we're so cooked Cuckoo, thank
you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Also, congrats to Raymaru, your faith in Doki, meant you won
the guessing game.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
14, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Do you ever get to play War Dogs with your buddies
yesterday, Doki?
I remember seeing you at the stream and then you're saying
you're back in the queue.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Okay, so basically what happened was, so we did need to
update the game, by the way.
Apparently there was an update that I didn't download
because my steam didn't pick up on it so when I quit the
stream and quit the game I was like I wonder if it does need
an update so I was like oh no updates showed up and I was
like alright but what if I had to log out and log back in so
I logged out so I logged out of steam and then logged back
in and then an update showed up and I was like are you
fucking kidding me are you that that was it that was oh my
god and then I booted up war dogs and I was in I literally
only waited like three minutes and i was in and i got in
right after i and then i was like fuck this and i had my ice
cream break i my ice cream was about to arrive i was like
i'm not gonna i was so mad i don't i think that was made
even i think if i had to still wait in the queue If I still
had to wait in the queue and like it had nothing to do with
anything else, then like that's fine.
Then I'll be like, okay, well, it's not mine.
But the fact that like it was because of an update and like
I got in instantly, the moment I updated, it made it so much
worse.
It made it, it made me so much more angry.
Like, yes, this could all have been solved.
plus hours if I simply just left the game locked out of my
steam locked back in and just tried to see if it was an
update it's just so much worse than it it's even worse of a
feeling than it being it was all for nothing
anyway what was like the twist of the knife was um was the
fact that I didn't enjoy it I I got on after the ice cream
uh right after the ice cream I didn't enjoy the game so like
I'm like well if I waited three hours and then I got in and
it found out I didn't enjoy the game I think that would have
been much more worse if that all happen in stream I like all
that just to not enjoy the game I that's the worst part of
it all I like I think at least at least I didn't wait all
that long and then and then play the game on stream just to
find out I don't enjoy it on stream I I think it also it's
also because I was really I was so tired it didn't help
that's already so fucking tired from waiting so long um I
think it was just everything I was already feeling like shit
I I was already like feeling like shit and then um and then
by the time I finally got on I apparently the team we were
on like uh the our group the group was split up split up
into two So like half the friend group was in a different
server.
So everybody was scattered around.
And apparently, the game I got in, the team was really,
really bad.
The team was really, really bad.
So we were getting absolutely destroyed.
I was overwhelmed and confused and everything.
So I couldn't like actually fuck around because we were
getting destroyed.
So I was like, I'm having a bad time.
And then I quit mid-match because I was like, guys, I'm not
having fun.
I'm tired.
So I waited four hours for this.
I'm so tired.
I, like, I was already coming in, like, tired as hell from
waiting in queue for that long.
And it did not help that we were getting absolutely fucking
destroyed.
And then Ben was like, yeah, you just were, you're just
really unlucky.
Whenever you join in, it is not the right time to join in.
Yeah.
And I'm like, I was like, I was so, I was like, it's not
fair.
and war dogs why can't i have fun in war dogs i don't
understand like i was just like really like but everyone
else is having fun with war dogs why can't i also have fun
in war dogs i it's literally what i said i was like i i i
want to join in i it's not fair I wanna have fun too.
They're all, everybody else is streaming the game for like
eight plus hours.
I wanna have fun like you guys.
I waited four plus hours for this.
Why can't I have fun?
Like, I'm so angry.
I just wanna have fun.
Look at this, do me what I said.
Why can't I also have fun?
yeah so i don't know maybe i'll try war dogs again another
time because like i don't know i don't know why it's not
like every it's clicking for everyone else it's clicking for
all my friends but it's not clicking for me but also i
happen to i happen to join in whenever the the matches
fucking suck i never get to join in when everyone is having
fun with the game
It's not fucking fair.
So, so that's what's going on with war dogs right now.
That's what's going on at the moment.
Other than that, fly update.
They made the, they taught the daily fly update.
They taught the fly how to play graves.
Apparently it's the only character that the fly can play.
And then a lot of grave players are not happy about that.
Because it's slander for grave players.
But yeah, so the fly can now play deadlock.
But only as graves.
Apparently that's the most success on grave.
For those who don't know.
you it's like are you smarter than a fly in deadlock is
actually pretty fucked up I swear to God the flies are
yellow than me I swear to fucking God a fly would be able to
play your character all graves main right now all target on
all grave mains that would be crazy Yeah, they made the fly
play McGuinness, but the fly did not like it.
Yeah, the fly got too bored.
Too bored on McGuinness.
Yeah, great mains in shambles right now.
Also, they taught the fly how to do a Rubik's Cube, too.
Oh, they taught the fly how to fly a plane.
Is that crazy?
Oh, what else can the fly not do?
Oh, yeah, they taught the fly how to be gay.
um like some guy was like can flies be bisexual and then
they're like after turning off a specific part of the brain
the fly what the fly can well sometimes choose like the male
fly as a mate they what yeah they taught the fly how to be
bisexual yeah by ruby like that turning off a part part of
the brain the fly has now become by bisexual um also so uh
also they taught the fly how to do a rubik's cube the fuck i
think that honestly like i said the most fucked up part is
that the fly doesn't even know it's not real what has
humanity done queer fly is there now Oh, real.
Oh, my God.
Fly yowey.
They're actually turning the flies gay.
So that current current fly update.
But can the fly see why kids love cinnamon and toast crunch?
Someone's gonna do it.
Someone.
And you say that as a joke.
Someone's gonna do it.
Lord, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Simple.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, this is your neighbor.
Can you please keep it down?
We're trying to watch TV.
Simple.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Aphelion.
Thank you.
If doom scrolling ruins short-term memory, imagine what doom
scrolling could do.
Thank you.
With a super chat.
Um, what else?
Uh, oh yes.
Also, um, I would like to use this stream to glaze my
manager and do a manager appreciation quick comment right
now because I fucked up yesterday and today I had like a
breakdown on my manager today because every time my manager
and I play Deadlock we don't get REM and like it's been like
eight plus games about it and then it happened yesterday a
manager appreciation segment here and then um so anyway so
yesterday it was like you won't play a bit of i was like i'm
feeling shit yesterday because like i would i mean there's
other stuff but also it did not help i waited three hours
just to not enjoy a game i so um so anyway um so my match
was like why how about we oh my god you have you eat your
food you eat you in your food i gave you the cat i gave you
the cat you saw the cat is empty that's not on me how does
he want more food i literally gave him all the food that was
possible anyway um
anyway um also my dog's definitely racist uh okay before we
do the management appreciation um so i went to the dog part
and it was like most dogs i've ever seen in a dog park for a
while there was like four dogs and like uh there was four
dogs at the dog part um and uh and there was like you know
four owners like four uh six owners there um and so uh
obviously dad was super happy and he like ran to the female
owners because there were three female owners He ran up to
them and was like, Hey, hi,
Lee.
And, uh, and anyway, so, oh, yeah, by the way, you guys
didn't know where Wiener dogs come from.
Uh, they come from Deutschland.
Um, anyway, uh, so, um, it was all, it was like a bunch of,
uh, female owners.
So there was three female owners and two male owners.
He didn't give a fuck about the guys.
And, but then there were four other dogs there.
I think like one two three.
Yeah, there are four dogs there and actually five dogs or
five dogs there And he ignored all the dogs the dogs wanted
to play with him They were like trying to like get his
attention walking up to him sniffing him He did not care.
He did not fucking care about them He was trying to get the
you know the women's attention be like hey Why don't you pet
me and the other dogs are like why don't you play with us?
Come on play with us And he was like ignoring all of them
and then so but then like the the female owners the women uh
was also sort of ignoring him because they were having their
own like uh conversation and stuff they pet him a little bit
and then they like were ignoring him and he was getting
really frustrated so then he went to i was sitting on the
opposite side so it was like you know they were all on one
side and i was sitting on the opposite side because like i
was just on my phone just waiting for him to poop because
that's all i need him to do he never poops when there's
people there so um so i was waiting for him to poop and uh
and you know I was on my phone and I noticed since like, you
know, the women weren't paying, giving him attention, he
just walked up to me and was just walking around on my side.
So it was like, and then it looked, it looked so bad because
it just, it's like, the thing is, um, um, everyone there on
the other side, uh, they were Hispanic.
So they're speaking in Spanish and everything.
And Adoki was on my side, like just like ignoring them,
ignoring them, not caring about them, not giving fuck about
the dogs.
And I showed a video to my friend, and then my friend was
like, is your dog racist?
Like, why is he not, like, hanging out?
And I was like, no!
He's just antisocial!
I'm just like, he's just antisocial!
He's just...
It couldn't be.
both and I'm like please dad just walk up to them don't be
on my side and walk up to him like so um I wish I could show
you guys a video because it's actually pretty funny Ali's
just like it's actually pretty funny because it's like he's
like distancing himself from them and I would docks my
location so like but it was a very funny video it was
because I'm like please dad walk please hang out with them
but he did not care about the dogs by the way he didn't and
then the thing is it was so crazy so the other dogs know it
seeing that dad is ignoring them they started up playing
with each other and then dad got mad he got really mad and
he's like because they were like playing like just trying to
like like um wrestling and stuff like that and then dad got
really mad and he like ran up to him and started barking
aggressively at them he was like stop stop and dad ran up to
them it was like stop he started barking and it was like he
doesn't even play with them he was just standing there just
stop stop stop playing and then the other dog stopped
playing it was just like what the fuck and he just kept
barking at this like stop and he doesn't even join him like
he he's just like like the other dogs are just playing with
each other and then he got mad he got mad that they were
playing with each other and just he literally stopped them
from playing with each other because he like ran up and like
stop and it wasn't like you know him being like fun bark it
was angry bark he was like um snarling and everything was
like showing his teeth and everything's like no no playing
no i was like oh my god what's wrong with you But, yeah,
you're...
What is his problem?
I know, I was like, what's your problem, bro?
Like, why won't you let them play?
Yeah, he was like, bro, is like...
And then they actually stopped playing, too.
And he did it several times.
Every time they start playing again, he stops them.
I was like, please, I was like, stop.
I was like, dad, come on, go.
No, no, no, stop barking!
And he'll stop barking.
And then the other dogs start playing again, and he'll tell
them to stop again.
He kept doing it, like, he did it like four times.
And I'm like, what's wrong with you?
You don't want to do anything with them, but they're not
allowed to have fun?
Like...
Oh, it's thinking of a super chat.
Thank you.
Rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem.
Doki, doki, doki, doki, doki, doki, doki, doki.
Yeah, I was just like, What's wrong with you?
They're not allowed to have fun unless he has fun.
Anyway.
People would generally just hate that they did not have
permission.
Maybe he thought they were fighting.
So he was like, stop fighting.
Like he was trying to be a mediator.
And he's like, stop fighting.
And maybe that's why he was like, he was like, all right,
you guys, stop.
fighting he's trying to like get himself in between them
like stop peace and love we didn't realize they were just
like they were just wrestling for fun yeah they forgot to
ask dad for his consent dad i'm sorry but don't give sorry
but dad is a fun hating karen gordon think it was super chat
thank you thank you sorry i think it was super chat thank
you you know dokey they say pets learn something to say
about that.
Neppers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I would love to see a dad episode of The Dog Whisperer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I'm having fun.
Dad, I'm not having fun.
Um, all right, anyway, back to my manager appreciation
story.
So, like, I was already at, so yesterday, I was already at
pretty shitty moon.
So now I was like, okay, we'll play some deadlock because I
haven't played Rem in a actually happened because i was like
speed running ivy unlocked so i can unlock uh uh rank and i
just finished ivy um i think two days ago so um um basically
uh what happened was that um you know we we have a very
unlucky percentage whenever we play i usually never get rem
so like every time we've played i've only had one one time
where i got rem anyway so we duode and i got ivy and i so
tilted already like i was already tilted uh tilted and we
lost a game too because like i didn't really feel like
playing ivy and i was just like i really wanted to i really
wanted to play rem i was really feeling rem and i wanted to
like remember how relearn rem and so so i was just like
because i i forgot i sort of forgot how to play him because
i've been like spamming ivy the last like couple of days
because i wanted to unlock i thought she was like the last
character And so I was already really tilted and mad and
then going in and then our second game and then the second
game I got I got Ivy again and then I was like I'm I'm I'm
miserable I'm so miserable right now really I don't want to
do Ivy again we just lost the game on Ivy.
I'm not feeling like Ivy I'm already having a shit day i'm
already not feeling great today like mentally and i just
wanted the you know i was already really down and then my
manager was like okay i'll leave the game before the game
started like it was like the warm-up phase the prep phase so
then he got like a three-hour ban for it um so he got a
three-hour ban for me uh and he left the game and then so
and then we had when then like you know we went to talk
about work stuff because uh there was like you know we we
got the band so we can't play deadlock anymore so yeah he
dodged the game for me because i i have a stream tomorrow so
we don't know how long my band's gonna be like i don't want
to risk it like because the last time i left the game
because i didn't get rem i got a i got a i think like a four
hour uh i don't remember it was a two hour band or a four
hour band i don't remember it was a two to four hour band so
i didn't want to risk it and it was like two weeks ago so i
didn't want to try that again because i don't know how long
my back my band i don't know how long the band clears so um
so i was just like all right and then uh my manager took it
took one for the team and dodged it because i was already
you know i was already having a shit day so he's like okay
i'll dodge the game for you anyway so we went to talk about
work stuff and obviously i was already tired i was already
having not a great day and then i didn't like i didn't
really want to do the work talk and then so like i was just
like it was just got like i was really like cranky and
everything about the work call and then he was like okay
okay we'll stop the work call but i was already super cranky
and i was in a really bad mood and then i was just like ah
like i was so i was in a terrible mood with the work call
and everything like that it started with bad deadlock game
and it ended with like me don't want to talk about work i
was like me don't want to talk about work well and so speed
run fast forward to today i was already sort of like post
crankiness i'm still cranky with all the work stuff and then
dead the hat couldn't even um play deadlock and then i was
still in a bad mood you know i was so rare you know and then
um and then so uh my manager like one or two deadlock games.
Maybe they'll cheer you up.
You get to do a little bit some REM before stream.
And then I was like, okay, I'll do some, I'll try.
And then I booted up, I booted up Deadlock.
And then we queued up together.
And then like an hour, like an hour and a half before
stream.
And then I got Ivy again.
And that was the last straw.
I was just like, why Ivy?
Why can we never get REM when we play together?
Silent, I don't understand, it's not fair.
Like, I was actually being crybaby mode.
I was, like, having, like, a semi-breakdown over it, and I'm
like, I don't understand.
I can't, why would we do a week?
I'd never get REM, and I was just, I was actually crashing
out, because I was, like, I said, I was crankier.
was cranky from yesterday and um I was just like do you want
me to leave I was like no no you already got a band from
yesterday I'm more you're gonna get a longer band and and
then it was like okay and then and that and then the middle
of like the first 20 minutes of game I like told him I was
like I'm not happy I was just like I What did I say I'm not
having fun Before stream Bad mood already getting Shittier
mood And like And then he was like Okay I'll leave game And
I felt so Bad
again And the song by the way it was all in standard and
then he we don't know how long his his bat is now but he
like another fucking dodge for the team and then okay so and
this is the worst part i'm so i'm having a breakdown over
this and then and then um i was like i'm having a breakdown
right now i'm crying Because I was like, that was like not
feeling good, you know, it's not feeling good.
I was like, oh my god, another Ivy.
Like, I just want to play Rem.
Like, I just want to play with my little chud son.
That's all I want.
The only thing that'll bring me, that'll make me happy.
And I can't even, they took that away from me.
And I was so sad.
And I was like, and I told my manager, I told Silent, I was
like, I was already having a shitty day.
I told you, I wanted to play Rem.
But we never get Rem when we duo.
before stream.
And I'm like, I'm already feeling miserable.
And he was like, I left a game for you.
And I was like, I know.
And he was like, there's nothing more I can do.
I already left.
And I'm like, but it's like, we never get it.
I play with 100 people all the time.
Why don't we get bread when we play together?
Like, and I was like, I just don't want to play ivy silent i
just don't want to play her like okay and then
and then i found out five like five to ten minutes later i
looked at my deadlock and i realized prios yesterday because
i forgot to turn that off after completing the ivy after
completing the ivy matches i forgot to un i prio ivy so it
was all my fault i i forgot to swap my prios because i i
just completed i so you saw the foreshadowing i foreshadowed
it uh it was all my fault so he he dodged for nothing
he dodged for nothing because it was so he he got mad for no
reason at all
and foreshadowing is a narrative device And I was just like,
before I found out, I was just like, I hate that, I feel so
shitty right now.
And he was like, I hate it all, so it's just a bad day,
tomorrow will be better.
And I was like, I just want to have one game on rent before
stream, and I can't even have that.
Like, I can't have any games on him.
And he was like, well, you hate I have you so much, why
don't you play other characters?
characters I I'm like I hate all the other characters I've
used the one that sucks the least I just want a rim because
I was already not feeling great you know I'm just I was
having a fucking breakdown over a rim and I'm just like why
why can I never get rem and then and then later like and
after all the breakdown ranting and venting about how I
can't play rem I'm like I'm so fucking stupid I forgot to
deprile rev ivy it wasn't even your fault I had rem second
prio I'm so fucking dumb I forgot to deprile it yesterday
what are we played
so so so this is a manager appreciation segment because he
is so patient for me with me he's so patient with me I had a
20 minute breakdown about why I can't play why couldn't I
play rem him and and he was trying his best to calm me down
and just for me to find out i i had ivy high priode he was
so patient and trying to calm me down it was just it was all
my fault i really appreciate silent for putting up with me
today and yesterday i was not the best person to talk to
those last two days um many thank you the super chat thank
you thank you how did he react when you told him he was like
wait that's funny lol okay that's kind of funny
wait oh i'll let me let me show you it he just wrote hey
that's pretty funny it's all he wrote i mean censor it
because it's not on his silent discord and he wants to stay
anonymous of his main he's so chilled he's european it's
just the european sense of humor i'm gonna hear you and
whatever here you are tell i was like having a breakdown too
you can sort of tell i was not i was not okay
here yeah i was
that was not okay finally
um kuka thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you bonus
for silent you earned it sir thank you for the akasupa uh
it's like okay uh papa smurf thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you oh maybe there's a rem priority streamer
in discord thank you super chat thank you thank you zastra
thank you for super chat thank you thank you took two
bullets for doki that she fired it's like i was like i was
standing at the edge of I was like I was standing at the
edge of the window I was like I can't I said help help I'm
fucking I'm gonna fall help me stop it and he's like stop
pushing I was like I know now what's going on he's like
grabbing on they please get away from the windows like I
don't know what's going on I'm at the edge help me help me
um thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um an
old it saying goes the problem lies between the computer
screen and the desk chair mike thank you for this super chat
thank you thank you thank you for your service silent
ninjitsu thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
for the silent appreciation fund thank you the super chat
thank you thank you silent thank you silent is the actual
strongest raccoon ever thank you the super chat thank you
thank you i'm gonna use the bathroom real quick guys i'll be
right back
thank you the super chat larry bear allen papa jay lecone
meddy aphelia neppers bite on four silent allen thank you
with a super chat thank you thank you so yeah like i said
huge shout out and appreciation to my manager silent i don't
know how he does it i'm like rereading my my I chat history
with him and I'm literally full on like having a breakdown
on him about how about the fact that I couldn't play rem and
how much I fucking hate Ivy and he's trying his best to calm
me down and then I'm and just for me to be like I forgot to
deprive Ivy I'm sorry you got bad for nothing I was just
like, I'm sorry for getting you bad.
So, really appreciate my manager.
He's like the one that calms me down a lot and stabilizes me
whenever I'm going through it, like little things that,
whenever I go through stuff and be stressed out.
And he has to, I don't know how he puts up with me.
uh and um handles me when i when i get a little cuckoo uh
yeah so yeah that's the the manager appreciation by the toky
center yeah the manager appreciation segment uh let's see uh
but yeah that's I mean, there was more.
I said a lot more stuff.
I said a lot more, but this was the most important part of
the whole conversation.
Other than that, I hope I get Rem.
I will fix the prior.
We're going to do some pubs because I need to remember how
to play Rem again before we go into Rank.
Rank apparently is solo queue only.
only um rink was apparently is apparently can only for
placements for placements it's solo queue only so i want to
see if i can grab get more frames out of this uh because
apparently my frames are like pretty ass uh for how i for
what it should be so let me check the settings real quick uh
do i need to turn off any of these guys area lights uh
Bloom and post-process bloom.
Do I need to adjust any of this, guys?
Def a field?
Do I turn it off?
Negligible?
Can I turn off all of them?
To Vulcan?
Rendering to Vul...
Oh.
Uh, well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Options here.
Okay, it's on...
Okay, we do Vulcan for that.
Okay.
Was there anything else, guys?
That's orange.
We'll disable the sliders.
Do we need to turn any of these down?
I have high-end specs, but for some reason, my PC is fucked.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll have to...
Maybe in the future.
we'll get a new PC and everything will be better for like
two to three months before it's be fucky again before the PC
realizes it's owned by dokeybird and then maybe not even two
to three months maybe maybe one month no this is dashboard
dashboard shouldn't matter I mean I'll put it to 200 just in
case it is I just don't know what's wrong with it.
I just don't know.
Do I need to turn any of these off?
Guys.
I mean, with all the games I have, with all the dumb games I
have installed on my PC, I will not be surprised if it's
used to mine crypto somewhere in the world.
I will not be surprised.
Turn off death.
Turn off all of them.
I don't know if that improved anything.
I mean, the game looks as ugly as it was.
Sorry, I'm not it.
The game isn't that ugly.
But the game looks just the same as it was.
But I could tell the frame is...
Let's see.
I don't keep my SSD on the red.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
This is on my other drive.
Let's see The QL lock mod Tanks my FPS Oh wait really?
The quality of life mod Tanks FPS?
Is it really?
I don't notice it But does it actually tank FPS?
I'll try restarting it here I do have the quality of life
mod on Let's see Dead lock mod manager all mods do that only
have it on because it's quality of life but it says quality
of life guys quality of life what do you mean if it's
quality of life it should be quality of life
Doesn't make any sense.
How is it not improving my quality of life?
All right, I'll turn it off.
Fine, I'll turn off quality of life.
Yeah, quality of life is supposed to enhance the quality of
life.
What's the point of it's not quality?
Quality of life.
Alright, let's see if it improves the frames.
I turned quality of life off.
Also, I found out apparently the higher frames you have for
Onimusha, the harder it is to parry.
I knew it wasn't me.
I knew it was a skilled issue.
I fucking knew it in my heart.
Yeah, if you have too many frames, the window to parry slash
easen lowers it's not cope it has been scientifically proven
yeah you have to like lock your frames or some shit why does
it take so long to load now oh no I turned off quality of
life and my my deadlock was not happy about it I
I knew it.
I knew it in my heart.
I wasn't bad.
It was the game's fault.
I fucking...
I fucking... In my heart, I knew it.
I...
I knew it wasn't me.
It's never me.
I'm gonna still have...
Yeah.
Let's see.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Boy, I like that.
Okay, let's see.
I'm going to look at my...
Let me see.
I'm going to look at what my task manager says.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
What?
Why am I 80-90% CPU?
What the fuck is...
Wait a minute.
That's not good.
okay wait give me a second that's 16 now okay just to take
it was because i tapped in and out maybe it's because i yeah
i tapped in and out okay that makes more sense oh yeah it
was uh compiling yeah all right let me go to sandbox real
quick all right it's fine everything is fine nothing to
worry about wait not sandbox i have to go to explore explore
New York City guys I've closed almost all my tabs I closed
the tabs that mad alright alright let's see explore New York
City and see where it takes me all right i just need to know
that okay 95 60 i don't know i still oh wait i don't know it
feels worse everything i guys i think turning up guys my
quality of life i turned up quality of life my quality of
life it got worse
of life it got worse everyone I look same to me I feel a
little laggier I can feel I it feels laggier now yeah that
I'm gonna turn back quality of life no you don't I can see
it my eyes can see it I can see it get deadlock mon manager
uh quality of life
closing out a thousand tabs i don't i don't know what you're
talking about give me real solutions guys gosh you think
this is a joke i want real solutions Not make-believe
solutions.
Okay, maybe I'll turn off.
Create a cloud.
Reformat your PC.
I'm turning back on quality of life.
So my quality of life would improve.
All right, there we go.
I don't know why it gives me.
silver always.
Starts out with silver first.
It's very annoying.
Okay, I think I'm ready.
I think I'm ready.
We'll just have... Oh!
Don't, don't, I think I'm ready.
I think everything's okay.
I think we're Everything's okay.
Guys, I'm ready for real.
I don't know.
Everything looks good.
For real this time.
It's okay.
It's just a game feature.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Everything is okay now.
See?
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
We're five.
All right.
All right, I'm ready.
All right, let's see.
All right, invite.
So I can guarantee REM.
This is the only way to guarantee REM, guys.
I adjusted.
I think I adjusted the sound settings a little bit.
Let me double check.
Gameplay.
Yeah, so you can hear voice chat a little better.
because apparently vc was a little low but let me know if
it's loud too loud or too low for vc um so in all right look
so yeah now i have rem high prior it's good to go now rem is
now high prior close the phone browser you have and you want
to open them up from recent closed tabs and one goes that
yeah yeah i just did that don't worry i just did that well i
didn't do it for all of them i just did that
I know it's like it's something to do with my PC Rem rem rem
rem rem rem rem rem rem rem rem rem rem rem rem rem rem Yes
Oh my van is on Vic either Victor or Drifter because they're
They're on the list They're on the list
Oh yeah I need I always forget my builds for I haven't
played rem by the way I haven't played rem in a while so
like if you think I'm bad at rem whoa get ready it can
always get worse
Okay, if we're aggressive, if you're watching this right
now, Gomez, if you're aggressive, I'm doing tag-along.
So if you want to go up to them, we can.
I'm run.
All right.
Oh, it's fine.
Oh, it's...
Oh, my God.
It's, oh, my God.
It's a Graves.
It's a fly on Graves.
Okay, but not that aggressive.
That's on you.
If you die, that's on you.
No one told you to go that aggressive.
Oh my god.
No, wait a minute.
No, I'm going to die for your sins.
No.
you said go aggressive i'm gonna die for his sins now look
at that that's my duo everyone that's come back that's my
duo the fly is owning her and i got the wrong power up too i
hope you're happy i i don't I don't have pillow.
I need to grab pillow first.
This is not looking out so good.
That's the fly!
Kill the fly!
Oh!
It's always my teammates.
Not all duos, but sometimes always my duo.
Alright, that's fine.
Alright, it's fine.
You know what's crazy?
I have more denies on Ivy than I do on Rem.
And I have less skins on Ivy.
A name that's a little sad.
Oh!
Oh hey, Mr. Prime.
The fly.
Hey.
I'm geising it.
What?
That name.
He's prime.
What?
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm scared.
Alright, I can't believe I forgot to do...
Guys, you can tell I haven't done...
I haven't done...
I haven't played Rem in a while.
Oh, Rem!
Rem is scared!
Alright, that's fine.
I have Pillow now, it's over for them.
I have Pillow!
It's over!
Oh, it might be over for my duo though.
Alright.
It's not fair.
He has...
He doesn't need an aim.
It's not fair.
I'm at 80 FPS.
Do you guys notice it, though?
If my FPS is low?
Wait, I see him over here.
Where's my duo?
Where is he?
No!
What?
Where is he?
Oh, I see.
Not all duos.
But somehow, my duos.
All right, I have extra charge.
Now I should be fine.
I am... What the fuck is this ping?
How the fuck did I TP?
Get out of here.
This is ours.
Guys, I don't think this is winnable.
I'm a little worried.
I wish I was helpful, Rem.
I wish I was.
Whoa!
I do boxes.
You're on your own.
Good luck.
I'm leaving.
It's okay.
I'm late game, guys.
I'm late game.
They might be pretty fed, but I'm laking, guys.
It's okay, I'm laking, Rem.
He'll be okay, I believe.
I believe.
Oh, God.
I can...
It's so...
I feel so slow right now.
I feel so slow.
Don't worry, he'll be fine.
He'll be so healthy.
out right now but he's he's so healthy right now oh we lost
our guardian
that's my bad you might not be as healthy as i thought he'd
be it's okay i'm doing boxes
it'll be fine there was no boxes here i thought this was a
box area i it's not it's his fault i've counted on him to
survive.
It's fine.
We'll be okay.
It was going to fall no matter what.
Even if I was there, he was not gonna be defending that.
There's a third on yellow.
Should we help?
I'll go help.
Bram's coming.
Wait.
Burn will be here soon.
Rem will be here soon.
Don't worry, Rem's coming!
Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem.
Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem.
Don't die.
Rem's coming.
Oh, Rem might be in a bad spot now.
Rem's here.
Rem is here to help.
Oh fuck.
Okay, I still got him.
I don't know what I pressed.
I still got someone.
I don't know what happened.
Oh my god, I was freaking out.
I was freaking out.
I pressed the wrong button.
Oh god, it's locked.
I don't know, it worked though.
It still worked.
Ram!
Oh, nice.
It's fine.
I thought he would go that way.
Grim!
Okay, I need a buy, though.
Alright, I helped.
I don't have Trophy Hunter, though, so it doesn't matter
with all the assists.
Okay.
Now I steal.
They won't know.
Oh, shit.
Okay, maybe I should start.
I really want to steal, though.
Alright, It's fine.
Oh, I'm so close to stealing that.
There you go.
I got my stuff back.
Ah!
It's fine.
I'm stealing that.
I deserve it.
Yum, yum, yum.
I'm stealing my own stuff.
Peekaboo!
There you go.
Look at that.
I know it's mine, but I deserve it.
It's like a little treat for doing a good job.
Actually stealing my own sinners.
Eh, I deserve it.
For a job well done.
I should help.
Three on yellow again.
I go over now.
Don't worry, Rem, Rem is coming over.
Rem, Rem, Rem is heading over.
Rem, Rem, Rem, Rem.
Rem is here, do not fear.
Okay, I wanted to give it to him first, but that's all
right.
All right.
I have some heals.
Yummy heals.
Okay.
Well deserved.
I'm gonna find this real quick.
All right.
I'm so weak.
All right, I'll go help.
all right don't worry oh shit there's three two more coming
there's the last come y'all should help out
just in case oh it would be cool if that hit though all
right we'll go back to the blue yippee
i'm just a little guy in this scary world Help!
Oh my god.
How did I not hit?
It was on my screen!
Crazy fly.
On my screen it looked like it'll hit him.
Guys, I say frames.
I would say it's the frame issue.
It's frames.
The fight.
Slow server frames.
Okay, not gonna lie, I thought my team was like next to me.
Ew, it's the lie!
I blame the lie!
God damn fly tech!
The stupid fly tech!
Good quill, thank you for the super chat.
Guys, I told you I forgot I'll play rem.
It's been a while.
I need to go into my tunnels.
It has been a while since I was in the middle.
I played rev I've been on Ivy duty for so long but I
remember my tunnels my one tunnel right here oh on green all
right coming over thank you need help on Greenwich I'm here
I'm here I'm here I'm here I'm here I'm here I almost forgot
where here was.
Get out of here.
Oh my god, where's the exit?
Oh, where's the exit?
Okay, I can help him for a little bit, and then I jump out.
All right, do you think he'll be fine?
He's so healthy.
Oh, I should go to green now.
All right, green is so healthy.
All right, here you go.
Oh, they're definitely grabbing that.
I'll just stay here.
Now I understand why people hate graves.
I get it.
I understand.
It's you.
Me understand now.
Your character can be played by a fly.
You can have brain damage and play Graves.
If a fruit fly can play Graves, it's not impressive.
Just be glad she isn't meta right now.
That's all I'm seeing.
If your character can be successfully played by a friend,
lie because maybe you should rethink your main you're no
better than a fucking insect exactly
don't worry we're licking red which day the griever are you
on
oh don't worry i'm here
why is there three people here there's nothing why do who
cares about your fucking guardians
oh i should go to blue blue blue blue oh no we're coming
broadway is under attack all right
what this is huge this is huge this is huge please flash
please flash
guys i don't think it's winnable anymore i know this the
toky pop yes that's me i told you it just took me a while it
just took me a while guys does i haven't played remon so
long i had to get back in the flow state.
Alright.
But actually, you're going doing that right now.
I should go green.
I'm going to go green to help them.
Don't worry.
I'm late game rem.
Do not worry.
It's late game.
Okay.
Oh god.
We're late game rem.
We're late game rem Guys
We're late game It's just simply late game guys
Everything will be fine
We're late game rem
Oh my god I'm gonna do nap time on him
There we go It's okay.
We're our entire team is late game guys.
Do not worry.
Our entire team is late game.
Oh, you'll see you'll all see
You'll all see when we all alt we all activate our alts.
Oh, you'll all see
Trust the frost We're all late game
That's just that's it That's just it guys
You'll see guys You'll all see how late game we can get You
all You all rule the day Late game activates Oh Late game or
next game?
Oh, shit.
Not our green.
Guys, why are we not protecting green, guys?
No!
Destroy the walker on Greenwich.
Oh, God.
I'm gonna go help green.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Don't worry.
Everything will be fine.
So rule the day of late game REM.
Ah, that's fine.
I wanted them to explode on me.
That's fine!
He gets nothing out of it anyway.
Oh, I could have got souls out of it though.
There you go.
Let's see, I can finally buy some things.
Don't buy disarming.
What is it supposed to be on?
Is this right?
Yeah.
Pull back.
Does he need help?
Don't worry, I got you.
Coming over!
I'll see I'll see when I reach my full potential Late game
rem I hope he knows How much I'm helping him right now
What can we do Okay Okay, maybe I'll buy it knocked out.
Maybe we don't need this arm.
I forgot they had a dynamo.
Oh my god.
Why me?
It's okay.
I'll scale.
I'll scale, guys.
It's okay.
I got...
I was panicking.
Oh my god.
I had so many things.
on me.
I know I could have double jumps.
You don't understand.
There was so many things going on.
Don't be a jerk.
They'll see.
They'll all see when my late game activates.
That's Let's see.
My potential.
When my pillow starts doing 2,800 damage.
Our yellow walker is under attack.
I'm going over.
Now I'm so slow.
I'm almost there, yellow.
I'm almost there.
Don't worry.
I'm almost...
Don't worry, I'm almost there!
These boxes are just a little side- I'm almost there!
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Where- where- what's going on?
What's going on?
Okay, okay, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I Can feel my power growing.
Good job.
All right.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Where is... Where is Lash?
All right.
Oh, what a slam dunk!
Glossy!
Okay, our Lash is dead, though.
Our Lash may or may not be dead.
Our... Our Lash might be dead.
All right.
That's fine.
Our Lash is still a Lash.
I?
Holy shit!
Alright, it's fine.
Our Lash lives those!
Graves is the reason I keep playing Deadlock.
She was the dead in Deadlock.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Need help on blue.
Okay, our Lash might be potentially be our best player.
The fact that he's lives those he's like yeah I hope he
lives that bonkai oh
wait mine because I'm greedy
oh my god he's so low sweet ram thank you for your aid all
right please don't let me die I think this is just it
I don't know where my team is fighting right now.
They're always...
Wait, I can steal while all this is going on.
Oh, no, I can't steal.
No, you can't steal my own stuff.
Alright.
Don't worry, don't worry.
I'll steal this.
Greed is good.
Oh, I hear them.
I actually hear them.
Wait, I don't think I can do it.
already they're already doing it never mind okay let me
clear out green then
are you serious that one that i hate graze they're so tanky
that like he just took up the entire pillow all right i
should help them i'm coming over i'm coming over green is
good i'm sorry it took me a while
Oh my god, I didn't realize they're right here!
Oh, that's very awkward.
This is bad for me.
Oh, this is very bad for me.
Oh my god!
I walked into that!
I actually walked into that I didn't see I'm banning graves
Indominable which one's indominable It's not in my build.
I don't know it Indominable the next chain is I or oh that's
guys we We need another slot.
I can't keep getting away with this.
If it's not in my build, I don't know what it is.
Guys, guys, it's late game.
We're not late.
When it hits 30 minutes, we're going to be ultra instinct,
guys.
The moment it hits 30 minutes, the ultra instinct will be
unlocked.
I'll eat the golden egg.
Oh, they didn't mid-boss.
I don't think we're doing it.
I don't think we can do anything about that.
I need another slot.
I'm so poor.
It's fine.
We all just have to live.
Oh, nice.
We unlocked the extra slot.
It's fine.
The extra slot worth it.
He's dying for our sins.
Wait, what the fuck?
He got a kill.
Wait, we got one rejuve out of the way.
It's fine.
It's worth it.
On.
Let's tag along.
I told you, it was all worth it.
Okay.
I can clear bite this next.
Alright, we just wait.
It'll scale, guys.
Just wait.
It's gonna start scaling.
We're just a little, we're just 20 solos behind.
It's nothing.
It's nothing, guys.
Oh, I hear a lot.
It's nothing.
I told you, it's nothing.
Big wave cut on green.
Are you serious?
Like, so unlucky for us.
Oh, you so low.
He is so low too.
That's not fair.
Guys, death is coming.
Hello.
Oh, hello.
He used refresher.
I don't like that.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
There we go.
Oh, he was so low.
I'm gonna heal little.
I'm just gonna heal everybody a little bit.
There we go.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
The fly is coming but we're so healthy.
Can I buy anything?
Alright, at least I can get the transcendent cooldown.
Yay, rejuve down!
Okay.
gonna do it.
I'm gonna steal it.
I'm gonna go.
They'll never know.
Oh, they already took it.
Never mind.
They know.
Ah, that would have been sick if I...
Why?
Why is my barrage just watching it?
I thought my barrage would turn around.
He didn't even turn around for me.
I was waiting for the mirage.
Get out of this little hole.
He didn't know.
I need him to look at me.
I was just wanted to be with my mirage.
I hope everything's okay over there He sided with the fly
He's a fly sympathizer You know I hope that fly Will forever
be trapped in graves Hell I hope that fly Farms you The
specific Fly that you can The specific graves that is
controlled by a Fucking sentient simulation fly why are they
flating rift ignorance is bliss you might hit
those at least
yeah it's just killing them
they got all these guys out of the way Okay, where is he
throwing that?
Alright, our graves is insane, not gonna lie.
I don't know if I can help you there.
I don't know if I can...
Here we go.
Oh my god, I don't know if I can help our lash, though.
Our lash is gone.
There we go.
I see you guys see it he wanted me he I saw it I saw him
fucking zoning in the meat I saw the leg
Yes Why me I What
Fuck off Yeah, fuck you!
Okay, let me clear this.
Clear this real quick for us.
I know, why me?
I don't know if we can do mid.
I don't have anything for this.
God.
Oh no, God.
Oh geez.
Oh geez guys I don't have a lot of damage everyone oh geez
oh guys we're not even close guys our damage is pretty
fucking shit everyone the whole team is almost there what is
our damage
Oh my god!
Oh I accidentally pressed you!
I accidentally pressed it.
I was trying to press E.
That's unlucky.
Why do we not just go for...
Yeah, I was expecting you guys to do a little bit more
damage than that.
I guess it took a long time.
I accidentally...
Yeah, we have no damage.
I was like, guys, why did we do mid?
Yeah.
It did take a while for anyone to get through.
Okay, but it wasn't me.
It's okay, we got late, the game.
We had...
I slept four people and we lash-alted.
That's not my fault.
I knew it was a bad call.
I was just like, guys, we're doing no damage.
Why are we doing this?
But I was like, whatever.
You, we do us, I guess.
I was like, guys, we're not doing any damage.
This is a right call.
I
had a feeling too.
I knew something was up.
It's not us as Mirage.
my god all right here we go
i mean i got a lot of people from that
what the what i can see behind me
guys it wasn't me it's not it wasn't me guys i will say i
don't think it was my fault i I will say I don't think it
was my fault.
The ritual is complete.
Oh, I saw my, oh, my game crashed.
It saw graves and it was like, enough.
My game actually crashed.
Even the game was like, enough.
I've seen enough.
The flight.
well done yeah so I meant late game I mean next late game
next late game it always gives me I swear I like do this too
what was it um settings yeah default hero I always pick rem
but it always still puts me on silver it's so weird I even
do it here but it's still um Yeah, it always makes me on,
uh, yeah, exactly.
Next game, guys.
Next game.
I don't know why it does that.
Let's see.
Is there another way to change it?
Alright.
I don't know.
Wait.
Wait, I gotta change something.
Oh, fuck!
Let's try and get rid of Graves.
Yeah, Ram.
14.
Thank you for super chat.
Do you think?
Guys, I'm just warming up.
This is a warm up.
Oh, my God.
Now I have Braves on my own fucking team.
Now I got the fly on my own team.
Yeah, disgusting.
All right, I'm not doing tag along first now.
Close quarters for opening rounds.
I don't know what kind of Chinese build you're on.
What do you mean?
I'm on sleepy little guy.
The only character I played in the beginning is he was fun
back then.
But now he's just...
There's nothing and then dies.
What do you mean?
You had to get on the game at a certain time to play it.
Yep.
I never thought about that.
She's crazy.
It's crazy feeling nostalgic for a game that's not even out
yet.
Should I actually change?
It's like they punish people for being V-Gens.
I'm gonna pillow first.
Oh, shit.
I'm against two people who are on the list.
I feel like half...
Honestly, not gonna lie.
I feel like majority of the Deadlock roster, they were on
the list somewhere.
Honestly.
Okay, I didn't shot shoot that guy.
Get out of here.
Don't touch me.
Just a little guy.
Alright.
Did we get denied or we did?
I didn't deny it.
It wasn't my fault.
I did not do it.
See?
Not me.
Alright.
What?
That's it.
I'm headshotting you.
I'm gonna headshot you.
That's it.
Mr. Goat guy.
Mr. Go, man.
Get headshot.
Oh, you thought you guys saw you.
See, I knew it was the Mirage Fault, not me.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, you don't like that, do you?
Oh, I don't like that either.
Alright.
Oh, that was he was supposed to On one of them, I fucked it
up
Oh Oh, I missed it
I missed the pillow I thought he would go the other way My
bad
You too, baby boy
Alright, it's fine I have pillow again, I have pillow
Oh, he's so low Oh, but you're so low, too.
God damn it.
Almost got him, too.
So I'm a stick burst now.
I don't know what it does, but I have it.
But it's there.
I have one of my friends who's been trying to coach me.
He was like, you gotta learn how you read your builds.
And I was like, we?
Do you read what your items do?
And I was like, I don't know, but I have it.
I guess I have it.
Oh, I know I have.
I know that does.
Weeding?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh, our camps are here now.
Alright.
Oh my.
All my duo is okay.
Yeah, he's fine.
I'll make sure...
I'll heal him up a little.
I know.
It's just... what do you mean, read?
Left to right.
If I left to right properly, I'll never have to read.
Why is he over there?
We already did our fucking spawn and shit.
Damn.
God damn it, got denied.
It's because you have high ground.
Oh my god, he was solo.
Nice!
There we go.
Tag along.
Exactly.
That way should be five.
I have the power of friendship.
I know, right?
Taking high ground.
That's cheating.
I'm going to do boxes.
Oh, wait.
My friend is...
Ready to see what a mole man can do.
Whoops.
Oh, I didn't want to give it to him.
Alright, there you go.
Rem gaming.
Wait, there's three people here.
God damn it!
You're not supposed to get that!
I see rate!
Kobe gotta help out because I want some of the money too
nice the goat is feeding that's why I like to see
okay I have I love
we have our own touchers
Ow!
Yeah.
I gotta go back to base, but...
Wait.
Wait, where's my team?
Where's my team?
Oh my god, he's so low.
He's just...
He's slashing me?
Alright.
It's fine.
Oh, we almost got him, though.
We almost killed the...
The goat.
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh shit, wait, we did!
No, let's push.
We'll see.
Oh!
Yeah!
Tagalog!
It's saved yet again.
Never punished yet again.
Let's go!
Yeah.
Oh, this is good.
I like to play with death.
Yeah.
Makes it more exciting.
When I live.
Makes it all the more exciting.
I am so under farm.
I don't know how.
He doesn't know I don't parry.
I don't melee.
I never, Barry.
So it does nothing.
He keeps thinking I'm meleeing.
It's a thrill.
When you're close to death and you live, it's just...
Whoa!
I hope we find someone walking alone.
She ain't bought nothing, Moe.
We can kill her.
I see rape.
Makes it all the more better.
I'm gonna steal it.
Why?
I didn't get the other one, so I think they took it.
I'm pretty sure they took it back.
I'm gonna steal it again.
I got it!
Wow, green is good!
Yeah!
What are we thinking?
Do I do this or not?
I see you?
I'm off.
Green is good!
Green is always good!
Headed to Greenwich!
Alright, let's call it.
I'm coming over to help.
I'm mad with power.
Whoa.
Let's stay here just in case.
Hey guys, I'm a little scared.
Ow!
All right, there you go.
It's all right.
I think it'll be five.
There you go.
I hit her.
I'm gonna be here a little bit.
And heal them up, too.
I want to try and, like, I want to try and sleep them, but
I'm scared.
I'm a little scared.
All right.
I'm gonna go through my tunnels now.
I think it's fine.
Tunnel time.
I should go this way.
Alright, I'll go help in yellow.
Alright, I'll stay here.
I guess!
I guess I'll stay here.
What the fuck is that magic thing?
Ow, it is!
Let's stay here and heal a little bit.
That's right.
I'm gonna do shit, I got heals.
Still, don't worry, I'm just chilling here.
Yeah, that damage is crazy.
I was not expecting that.
Well, I guess you'll continue to be 1 HP.
There you go.
Alright, I guess I'll stay here again.
I'm gonna steal my own shit.
Fuck it.
I deserve it.
I deserve this.
Mine.
Oh my god.
Never mind.
Oh, are you serious?
I wanted to be greedy!
This yokey is greed.
Yes!
Greed will and will always be good!
It's fine!
I'm gonna go try and kill him.
I'm gonna do it.
It's a little rascal trying to kill him.
Oh shit.
I didn't need it anyway.
I'm coming, Moe.
See you guys?
Think I didn't steal it.
I'm heading over.
Everything should be fine.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, that's bad for me.
That's bad for me.
That's so bad for me.
I think we're playing the game.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
They don't never expect ring around the rosy.
They never expected it.
That's right.
It's because I'm so tiny.
And I do what I want.
Who is Jason?
I don't care.
I live those.
That was awful.
Oh shit.
They never expected.
Our new walker is under attack.
Need help on yellow.
I don't think dog.
I know.
I'm ramming it right now.
I'm on yellow too.
I feel like I should get... What was it?
Extra regen, right?
There's yellow.
It's fine.
That'll be fine.
I'm ramming it.
We didn't need that.
We're fine.
We didn't need it.
I'm gonna steal it.
Oh, they're on it.
Never mind.
They're literally on it.
I can't steal it.
Can't get me when I'm in my tunnels.
Oh, shit.
I think our mode would be fine.
Mina, stop playing the game.
Stop playing the game.
If that's what playing the game looks like, stop doing that.
Not Rem, though.
Rem can keep playing.
Rem doing his job.
Rem's scared.
Rem did not realize that's where everybody is.
Rem didn't know.
Rem didn't know that's where everyone is.
Okay.
um it's fine are we gonna be fine oh i need knockdown though
for sure what the fuck all right i'll take it ram is just a
little guy
really is that not the old uh yeah what's the all for well
there were a lot of things different like uh they were on
our side of the map you know taking our walker and uh i
don't know kind of kind of a good fight for us generally oh
he's in there it's not on their side of the map it was not
1v3 and nobody died that was the big difference nobody died
well everyone man everyone mad oh fuck i'm sorry there was a
tree people never defend their shitty opinions in the voice
I'm RIM!
You're either really nerdy or...
Don't be a jerk!
Oh, RIM's scared now.
RIM?
My girlfriend.
Oh, RIM!
I got the kill!
I gotta kill him!
I'm gonna not die here.
Come on, Mina.
Let's do that together.
You want to hold my hand?
Let's be buddies now.
Let's be friends.
Come on.
If you died, who would miss you?
What the fuck?
Oh, my god.
Oh, it was healing booster.
Okay.
Holy shit.
Oh, I don't think they're okay yet.
Riff is green?
A villain arc!
Headed to yellow!
Bro, I'm saying, Mo.
What a lovely day to game.
What a lovely game.
Lord accurate, mean.
Oh, wait.
I'm...
Wait, actually...
No, I'm not on your farm.
Headed to farm.
He dug his grave, I saw that.
Grab my cooldown so I can maybe get not all Amina players,
but all Amina players.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I always got worried.
I now take it.
Alright, just in case.
Alright.
Anyone else I can...
There we go.
Alright.
I think I hit this.
Aww, I thought he would go left!
He didn't go left!
Yup, go here.
All right, I'll be five Well, unless I got somebody Somebody
stop me Yeah I leave I leave now Somebody stop me somebody
stop Oh my god, somebody he do stop me i saw them running i
got scared he wants to grab he's looking for it
he actually he was looking to stop me guys just over here by
double centers by knockdown too all right go run get blue
Oh, I thought he would go that way.
I thought he would go left side.
Oh, my god.
Where is he?
Let me.
All right, it's fine.
Victorious is safe.
it was nice knowing you what the fuck is the light okay to
be fair this guy is playing he is he's playing fucking mo
and krill saying that that would be okay right it's his turn
it's his turn all right there we go mull down.
I drove a deep help.
You tell about you too.
I bought a lot of time.
I was wondering if it happened to the others too.
My dokey YouTube has no mouth.
Wait, Really?
Really?
Steve, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, sorry.
Super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Is it actually?
Yeah, playing Mo and Crow revokes revokes your privilege to
talk.
Mina, does it upset you to see people having fun with the
chat and not being hateful and mean?
Does this guy, is this guy a record player?
LOL, LOL, LOL.
Holy shit.
You're bashing him now.
Oh my god.
This is league.
This is going to be league next week, guys.
Get ready for league next week.
It gets worse in league.
Not really.
Mo does.
Mo thinks you're mad as hell.
Why is everyone so mad?
Oh, did I buy it?
I did.
Uh-oh.
Drama.
I think you have a crush on Nina, Victor.
Ooh.
Let's sacrifice a goat, man.
Whoa!
well don't fight don't fight honey buy one item okay so
taking my way down down Billy stood hell yeah 7 get that
bitch hell yeah that's funny as fuck oh yeah you got that
yeah you got the
ah I'm sorry, bro.
I love you.
I'm gonna stop like calling you out What do I do in that
situation?
I am so I get hit by everything I think I bring a positive
energy to the game Holy shit I got dude.
I couldn't even press Q on anything But also less people
play the game Oh my gosh.
There was nothing I could do.
Or I'm healing temple.
Rift is on green.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh.
That was very unfortunate for me.
Deadlock when you overextend for a zero point.
Honestly?
Yes.
like they want it they're probably just gonna roll blue here
that's how I feel right now I was literally ahead for one
second Perry what's that what's Perry I'm doing no Perry run
right now guys This is a no-parry rem run.
Oh, God.
I see all four of them.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
You're so low.
Oh.
What's going on?
Where is everybody?
Okay, I don't know where any of the fight was.
I just hoped everything was going to be okay.
Yeah.
I leave.
Rem is lost.
Rem's scared.
Oh, wait.
I'm not even close to any and I'm a little bit more.
Holy shit.
What the fuck has...
I've already seven been doing.
I can grab this.
Oh, I don't have it.
And you have fire more, though.
Oh, I have so little.
Maybe I can grab this.
No, I think the...
Oh, whoa, whoa.
I'm greedy, I'm greedy, I'm greedy.
But it's worth it, it's worth it.
What do I do again?
Uh, alt F4.
Alt F4.
That's fine.
No fucking way he just did that.
There is actually no way he actually...
There's no way!
Oh, there's no way.
Did he say LF?
Yes, he did.
Oh, F4 did not work.
That's weird.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
I can't believe it didn't work, guys.
There's no way that didn't work.
That's crazy.
Oh my.
I can't believe it didn't work.
Oh my god, hey little guys.
Oh no.
Oh the dad's like, what didn't work?
Oh yeah, I need to grab heels.
Yeah, three are down.
go mid all right i need to go grab buy stuff and i can go
mid i'll boost up all right there we go oh this trick in the
book this i got it yes got my stack I did it.
Got my stack, guys.
Oh, my God.
Dad, this is going wild right now.
I'm greedy.
Oh, my God.
Dad, Dad, please.
I'm greedy.
I'm coming, seven.
Get that guy out of there.
There you go.
I'm so hungry.
Oh,
that's a lucky almost.
Oh, I got it.
All right.
There we go.
We got both.
You know what?
Kill this guy for fun.
Come on.
Nice.
Oh, where the fuck is the holiday?
All
right, get the last stride.
Come on, let's go!
I'm Rem!
All right.
That was this time.
How do I drop the fucking urn?
I picked it up by accident.
We'll all learn.
Don't be here yet.
Don't be here.
It's just all F for.
Hold F word?
I keep thinking that one is cleared.
They'll do not hold F word.
But what if it works this time?
I'm gonna steal my own iron.
You know that is?
Well, no, we don't want to lose the game.
I'm stealing my own stuff because I don't want to...
Because I can!
Usually the premise of playing video games, games to win all
right okay watch this I can grab this though all right I'll
see you in a minute read is good surely they won't know I'm
here wait they're fighting oh shit okay but all right we're
five wait my guy does not want to go and rift i'm just gonna
oh my god my guy is oh my god no way that just expired all
right go to rift i guess
headed to york yeah i know it goes away but i just did it
just to Just to fuck with people a little bit.
You know?
Alright then.
Alright.
What does he have?
What
does he have?
Oh wait, what does he have?
Oh wait, what the fuck?
No!
There you go, I stunned him.
Where is... where is he?
Oh, I got him.
Is there anyone else?
Okay, I don't know who I hit!
No, he's won!
Oh, nice.
Who's what?
Yummy!
Alright.
Well, I think we win.
Nice.
Now we keep going.
Where's our graves doing?
Good game.
What the fuck?
Our graves are like in there.
Yo yo.
Yippee!
Just that easy.
Look at that.
I told you.
I'm like, I told you.
My late game activates.
Late game.
As in second game.
That's where the late game comes into play.
Doki will make winning place and immediately get Oh look Oh
look at that I'm I'm MVP too I'm a 2vp The late night
sleeper build I told you more damage than the Mina Hey, no,
no food.
You saw the, you saw the can.
No, go.
There's no food.
You saw the can.
There's no food in the can.
Okay, let me actually redo my build.
I feel like I should add the healing.
Uh, I wonder if I do it here.
Okay, I feel like I should add healing higher.
healing booster I'll do healing booster no no and you're
gonna see later when become an eternal that's that's fun
like I in my dreams you mean kuka thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you um your favorite donut shirt just
popped in my head because why not It's made me curious if
you have been enjoying any long, creamy French pastries
recently.
I like...
I'm not really a fan of, like, pastries in general.
I mean, I like cakes.
I like tiramisu.
I like sponge cakes.
Oh, sponge cakes are really good.
I love sponge cakes.
Uh, all right.
Mr. Nus-Nus-Jester, please.
Thank you.
The Butter Lord.
all right um okay i want to put healing booster higher i'll
put it here i'll put healing tempo oh my gosh whoops no i
fucked it up i'll do this first your family and once you
summon the archmother you will see that where is healing
booster oh no oh no wait they're all gone Wait, no, I fucked
it up!
Oh no, I fucked it up.
They do lots of things.
I messed up.
My thing got messed up, guys.
I like candy.
Or a gun.
Probably candy, but maybe a gun.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Can I kill my minions?
There you go.
I tried Ube before.
I like Ube.
I'm worried if...
I don't know.
I think my favorite pastry is sponge cakes.
I need sponge...
Is it sponge cake?
Like the really soft cakes.
I think it's called sponge cake.
Oh, chipon cake!
No, no, no!
Sorry, it's chipon cake.
I meant chipon cake, not sponge cake.
Chipon cake is my favorite type of pastry.
Yeah, I like...
Chifan.
I always love doing crime.
I got confused with the name.
Yeah, I love just how soft Chifan kicks are.
And I shouldn't shoot them from so far.
But I'm gonna do it anyway.
Grab pillow.
I don't have to die.
Look.
That's bad for us.
Come over here.
Already used pillow.
Oh my god, he knows the timing.
Nerd!
That's a nerd if I didn't see one.
Imagine knowing the exact timing for when minions spawn in
standard.
Imagine that.
That's my duo.
Fucking nerd.
I need a buy.
you guys should try chiffon cake it's really good it's one
of my favorite it's one of my favorite pastries hey um if it
was an ice cream cake I would get chiffon cake I'm gonna
close
okay oh my god he whiffed me that's creepy yeah I how soft
it is in general.
When is Jokey gonna play rank?
I just need to remember how to play rem because I haven't
played him at all last couple of days.
So I'm like pretty um...
I'm very rusty on...
Oh!
Shit!
I'm very rusty on him.
This is like my third rem game in a week.
Oh my god, you fleek!
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, he is so dead.
It's okay.
I just didn't have tag along.
Okay, now I do.
Everything will be fine.
I have tag along now.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Yeah.
I already unlocked Rank right now.
I just...
Rank is solo queue, though.
So, like, I'm gonna be playing Rem.
And, uh...
I just want to make sure I don't get...
yelled at.
Well, I will, I'm gonna get yelled at, but, you know, I want
to make sure that I know for sure I'm getting yelled at, but
I want to get yelled at less, you know?
I want to be yelled at less, though.
Alright.
He's, like, over there.
Yeah, he's so alone now.
Oh, I'm backing up.
to make sure it's warranted every time they yell at me it
might be warranted
i have extra charge oh our camps are ready i'm gonna do it i
don't care if gomez doesn't get it i don't care my duel
doesn't get it i'm gonna do it
my camp
It's my camp.
You can't, you can't, no, you can only, if you're doing
placements, you can only solo queue placements.
And you have, I think the worst part is like, it's eight
games.
That's fucking, I don't know.
That's too many.
Eight games is too many games.
Don't be a jerk.
Oh, what the fuck?
I don't know why I thought he would go left side.
Eight games.
That's eight hours!
Deadlock is too long.
Deadlock is too long for it to be eight.
You guys did not know how long Deadlock games go.
That's like at least eight hours of gaming.
Yeah, we got it.
Look at this.
Oh shit.
That's an unlucky up.
It's almost...
Oh!
He's gonna get him.
No!
I'm just gonna get me!
I'm sorry for laughing!
I didn't mean it!
I didn't mean to laugh at you!
Yeah, at least I'll get my heal, though.
I didn't get my heal.
I lived, though.
I lived.
Never punished.
I'm going to go to...
I'm going to go to Blue.
That'll be fine.
Me go Blue now.
Holiday's going to be fine.
Oh, sinners soon.
That's so true.
But sinners win.
oh I don't want to go through right now guys guys I need you
guys to nerd it out for me sinners now I could help I could
help or or
okay I'm sorry I'm giving this myself I did a good job for
myself for a good job well done I did I earned it I did okay
I need a where is it Where did my other build go?
I'm such a team player.
Weed is good.
Maybe when I die and you find it.
Oh, we have to go back to yellow.
I got trophy collector too, which is good.
I actually needed that.
I don't insta-kill things yet with my pillow.
So, I gotta work on that.
Thank you.
On the right side, that's heal booster.
Yeah, there's something wrong.
I had it cute, but then all my stuff disappeared in my
queues.
Where's the hot?
Oh, there it is.
You'll boost it.
I'll get heal booster here.
And then where's healing tempo?
I had healing tempo.
Okay, there it is.
I have healing tempo here.
I'm gonna do it
Guys there's a fly Guys the fly is here All
right, well, I did my best I did my best not my fault It's
not my fault
he's got the urn let's push blue isn't he got the urn it's
he got the urn rep is on green
i did my best it was a try he hurt me oh but i could oh nice
you got him Oh, we're still graves, though.
Oh.
So I'll do this first.
Alright.
Can we get this?
Yeah, we get it.
Alright, nice.
Oh, wait.
Let me put this on these guys.
I mean, you know what?
Fuck it.
Oh, never mind.
Not fuck it.
I'll go.
Wait, actually, is he actually gonna fight it?
I can't tell.
Is he that crazy?
Nah, he's not that crazy.
I'm gonna leave.
I wanna do tunnels.
Tunnel time!
Boop!
Good luck not getting shot!
My little home.
The only route I know.
Oh, I should help.
don't worry don't worry Maurice I'm learning how to use the
stairs this little guy that could I'm here thank you I need
a bad knockdown I forgot they haven't flash I am headed to
blue I am pretty helpful oh shit you're fine all Back into
my tunnels, I'll go.
And then my second tunnel.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right, there you go.
Back into my second tunnel.
I think it's like here.
And then through here, I go here.
And then more tunnels.
Yippee!
The only tunnel route I know.
Oh god, I gotta help.
Don't worry!
I just need to find the exit!
Rem's coming!
Oh, there's- there it is!
I found the exit!
Rem here!
Moe and Crow!
Rem is here!
Where is he?
I'm the French!
No!
Oh, this is so bad for me.
Room here.
Yeah!
Rem is helpful!
Okay, oh my god, that ricochet though?
I told you, Rem is here.
Have no fear.
Okay, I need that cool down stuff anyway.
All right, now I can buy.
All right, let me buy now.
Fuck, don't you fucking freak.
This is why you have...
Really?
Come on.
Yeah.
Are you happy about that?
Did you enjoy that?
Yeah, I still...
Good skill!
I stood still for you!
Wow!
Beautiful!
Wow, the most skillful gameplay I've ever seen.
Yeah, you see, no fear.
All right, I gotta help them.
Where are they?
Oh my god, he's like so far.
Like, what the fuck am I gonna do?
Shoot him!
Oh, he could shoot me up, but you don't shoot him off.
Oh my god, wait, he actually went for him.
What the fuck is wrong with him?
Holy shit.
Wait, wait.
I did not expect that.
All right, there you go.
I'll help him a bit.
I actually don't think he expected that.
All right, that's fine.
Wait, there is it.
Oh, I fucked him his run.
I take those.
how does he have it okay that's i mean i'm doing my best i
mean i'll heal you through it
i don't know what you want me to do i don't have pillow
maybe that's a little
okay we did it oh my god
i'll take those oh pick me please please okay here you go
you're so healthy You are so healthy.
Oh my gosh, he's so low.
There's the best I can do in the situation.
No!
Ah, no!
I can't do it anymore.
Okay, he knocked down.
Let me find knockdown real quick.
I'm breaking.
I got prunked by my lash.
He's like, hey, you want me to go back?
I was, please, lash.
I just, please.
I got prunked by my word.
He's like, you want me to go back in again?
I got you.
You know what that means.
They saw the rude chat.
What?
No.
All right.
He's so lucky.
I don't have enough money.
I'm poor right now
Exquisite work said I do want to farm a little I'm gonna
farm a little bit But we got the thing at least
All right, oh I'm getting stronger now Wait, what?
I'm gonna do cool, guys.
Don't look at explosion moment.
Okay, time to time.
Boxes should be up.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm heading over to yellow, I guess.
I'm such a slow...
Wait, I have so many stacks.
Oh, wait a minute.
Huh.
I'm not slow.
I have stacks.
He has like that.
He has like that movement.
I just did.
Oh my god, he's coming.
He's coming.
All right, that's fine.
Oh, no, I just okay.
Let's wait.
Someone's gonna get blue, right?
Someone's gonna get blue.
Okay, good.
I can steal the sinners then.
I'm just gonna go for this.
Oh, holy shit, wait, I was killed him.
It was worth it.
I almost killed him.
Nice, I got it.
I got it.
I'll help Venator.
Is there a Venator will live?
This doesn't feel very safe.
Oh.
Don't worry, I got you.
It's round two!
Oh, thank God he didn't go for round two.
That was both things.
Thank God.
I did not want him to go round two.
I got really worried about him.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Okay, this guy's movement is actually insane.
This guy has crazy ass movement there.
What?
There's a victor out here.
Oh, they have a rift.
fine.
I'll go up.
Should be fine, right?
You go up, Victor!
I got this!
I can solo this, Rift!
Yeah, I can solo this.
What the fuck?
Is he okay?
I don't think I need to use anything.
not gonna lie got it now heal him uh oh that's awkward now
go back to yellow go rim yeah that's right it's my town okay
i'm gonna speed up just to save yellow watch this kobe
Yeah.
This guy has reported me through my slurs!
What's going on?
Someone's not having a good game right now.
Whoa!
What the fuck is going on, guys?
Why can't we be friends?
After I get this.
Greed is good.
Yippee!
Where I think...
You're too late!
Oh, what the fuck?
Victor's here.
Let's take out Victor!
What's wrong with you?
Why are you here?
Yeah, I know, what is wrong with you?
Holy fuck!
Is there something I'm supposed to be doing right now?
That's it.
That's not it.
That was not it, apparently.
Don't worry, Mo.
Oh, our blue walker, though.
Oh, that's not good.
Why are you...
Because I got lost!
That's why.
I forgot where things are!
I couldn't see anything.
I was blind.
The giant walker was in my head.
Are we doing mid boss?
Okay, I'm gonna clean up this way first.
Is there's more?
I just cleared it!
Or are my tiny little men?
Here you go.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Another blue walker.
Alright, I'm coming over now.
The little guy who...
Who could is here.
Don't worry, I'm here.
Wait, where's everybody fighting?
Oh, shit, it's downstairs.
Don't worry, RIP's coming downstairs!
Ah, the fight's out upstairs now!
Don't worry, Rem is coming back upstairs.
There we go.
There we go, guys.
I'm here.
Don't worry.
The little train that good is here.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm trying to see who heals the most.
I think everybody's fine though.
Alright, nice.
There we go.
Down!
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
We take the scenic route.
It's fine.
I think we're good.
I mean, we have rejuice still.
Are we- alright?
Oh wait.
Oh.
That's fine.
Wait.
Uh...
Greed, Greed, Greed, Greed, Greed.
Greed time!
Wee time!
Yippee!
Wait, there's more over on the other side.
Oh, I- we got the rift too.
Wait, I should spend my money.
Money, money time!
Oh.
There we go.
Oh, wait, I can buy one more.
Alright.
Yeah, guys, remember when I couldn't hit those guys?
Guys, guys, remember?
Remember when I couldn't hit those?
Guys, guys!
Guys, remember?
Oh, goodbye, seven.
Come, drink them.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's because our seven used rejuven.
Okay, I forgot our seven had rejuvenated.
I could have came back for it.
Whoop.
Shoulda, shoulda, woulda.
What were you doing?
Were you not pushing lanes?
I killed a man.
You sure he did?
I'm gonna say you guys win.
I hugged him.
I'm gonna try my damn dish.
I'm counting the old from the top right corner and they only
used three.
I only used three.
Yeah, gosh, you've got to keep it fucking accurate, man.
We need good callouts.
Shut your big ass nose up.
Shut up.
Wow.
Holy, what a beak.
All right, mom.
Shutting this open box just nose up your bum bum, bro.
No!
Joke on you.
I like that.
It's going to be gooey.
Oh!
I do not want my boogers.
Oh, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my,
my, my, my, my, Please!
Oh, please!
Please!
Oh, even Dad knows that things were funky and things were...
I'm alive!
I went through so much today!
I'm alive?
I'm alive!
I went back!
There you go!
We got it.
I'm alive.
I'm alive!
Yippee.
Yeah!
They're about to be five of them, Sonny, and you're about to
go.
Accidental?
Oh, skill.
What do you mean?
Accidental.
Everything was done with a purpose.
That's crazy that I still hit me.
That's crazy.
I still hit.
Alright, here you go.
Oh, I need that gun buff.
I need it so bad.
Let's end the game.
I know I can do that, but like I need the gun buff to do it.
No, no, I do!
No, you don't, man!
No!
I'm darling.
This game's gonna go for an hour and a half.
You know you love me, right now?
No!
What the fuck is...
Oh my god.
I have a vision.
I just believe it's sleep.
I...
What the fuck is going on?
We returned the monkey we killed.
We actually reverted back the monkey.
Yippee!
We won!
Yay!
We did it!
We did
it!
Easy as to win.
Yay!
That's me!
Holy shit!
Okay, guys, I think I invented her.
I think I invented her to carry that heart.
Not gonna lie.
If only Lee can't voice...
Ah, next week!
Next week!
It's gonna happen!
You thought this was crazy?
wait for next week.
Whoa.
And sweet, let's meet, let's meet.
Yay!
Okay, let me fix my build real quick.
I want to put a healing booster up here.
And then I'll put healing tempo.
I'll do it like...
Yeah.
I'm going to do it after trophy collect.
I'll do it after trophy collect.
Okay.
That's me, that's me, that's me!
Yay!
You gotta change it on the right side?
How do I change it on the right?
Edit.
On.
How do I change it?
Is it because it's left to what?
Is that it?
How do I change my cube build stuff?
Can I just drag it?
Why don't where's my cube build?
Snowy!
Thank you again!
Thank you always for the 50 gifted chips!
Snowy!
Thank you!
Oh my god, thank you again.
so supportive i really appreciate it snowy thank you i'm
gonna drag it here oh oh under upgrades and oh i see okay
what i'm in that's me when what happened to my duo He's got
it.
Okay, I'll put it here.
I'll put healing tempo.
I want it, I mean after.
And I'll put healing booster.
After, actually I'll put it here.
And healing tempo, I'll put it after rapid recharge.
Or...
Oh, yeah, after.
There we go.
Oh, no, he's here.
He just didn't load in.
I think my favorite so far was when they returned to Monkey.
I know you're getting better.
Guys, I'm improving on Rem.
Okay, I think I'm like, my aim on Rem is actually pretty
good.
I'm not gonna lie.
The fact that we are about to stare death No, a god in the
face and see if he blinks first.
I'm, I think my, I think my, my, my pillow, my pillow ain't
my red, not gonna lie.
Pretty sick.
Try opening.
Opening rounds instead.
Opening rounds.
I'm gonna try.
Versus close quarters.
But then me broke.
Oh shit.
Bro, put us in opening?
No, not Paya.
Don't shoot it.
Thank you.
Oh my
god, my last shot I missed.
Okay, somebody got denies, and it's not me.
Let's see.
Okay, I'll delete closed quarters, then.
But it don't take me a while to farm it.
That's the only issue.
You fucker!
Okay, this time it's my fault.
This time it's me.
Look at that scene.
No, I don't carry.
I don't melee.
I'll figure that out in another time.
I'll learn that another time, guys.
They do lots of things.
I missed the bitch.
Hello.
What?
Okay, that's bullshit.
That should have been a hit!
Fucker.
Oh my gosh.
I'm sad.
That should have been a hit.
Fuck you.
Oh, he's so low!
He's one, he's one!
Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
I tried to parry.
You guys see that?
I have character arc.
There was a character arc.
Oh, not you.
I was trying to give it to you.
There was a character arc moment.
No way.
And also, it's not all victories, but...
maybe most big dudes what does he mean by that okay I'm
scared a lot of people are missing right now I can snap I
see warning I have no I need hundred I'm not Close that,
uh...
Oh, just in case.
Just in case.
Oh, all right.
Yeah, I baited.
I- I- I had hope that he wasn't gonna hit it.
I gambled that.
I know you'll help me.
Isn't that...
Just because I can.
Wait, who's on me?
Oh, that guy.
I say, who the fuck shot me?
Oh.
Alright.
I think we'll be five.
Do not work.
Whoa.
That's not fair.
Those are my friends.
Damn, that guy was scared.
That guy was so scared.
That was like a pussy.
What's he gonna do?
Shoot me?
Ha ha, that's fucking right.
Yeah!
Oh, okay.
Alright.
I thought he was gonna do something else.
Not gonna lie.
God damn it.
I thought he was gonna fucking walk.
He was so slow.
He predicted his movement perfectly.
He just was like 20 frame...
He was like 20 ping behind.
I don't care.
I don't care my duo doesn't get this.
I'm not... I'm a team player.
I'm a team player.
Who is he shooting at?
My bling ping?
Are you serious?
Okay, that should have hit.
That 100% should have hit.
Alright, he's fine.
It's the frames, guys.
It's the frames!
Do you not see it?
I'm literally on...
I'm playing...
I'm getting debuffed.
I'm literally playing with 60 frames right now.
Oh yeah, no, he's dead.
There was no saving that.
Yeah, wait, actually, what happened?
Oh, we...
Don't you just hate it when he just punches you?
Oh, where's my little guy going?
You're buying, helping me buy stuff right now.
It's fine.
What you...
Guys, I might have head a little bit too soon.
I...
I might have...
Head...
I might have prematureed head.
I hate premature.
head guys.
It's not fair!
There's three!
Not me!
No such thing.
I haven't seen a lot of it.
I'm fucking, I'm doing sinners.
Actually, I'll take this first.
I'm gonna steal that one.
Oh, no, they're doing sinners right now, too.
I think our lash is dead.
I think our mirage is dead.
I leave.
I can't handle that.
I'm just one guy.
I need a buy knockdown, though, for real.
Alright, I'm here.
Protect.
I'm like the final stage.
I'm like the last frontier.
The last stand.
Plans key.
If all else fails.
Just a little gap.
Could they take our sinners here?
Yeah, I'm gonna go grab you.
Oh no.
It's fine.
They got this.
All right.
I can tunnel.
Wait, actually.
Actually.
Do you think that warning is coming over?
No, right?
There's no way, right?
Yeah!
I take those.
Yeah, let's go!
Yum-yum-yum-yum-yum-yum-yum-yum.
Greed is good.
Oh, I'm so hungry, Maurice.
I'm so hungry.
Oh,
this one will have something.
I knew it.
All right, we'll help.
Well, good thing I'm here.
Someone fucking come help.
Don't worry, guys.
Little REM that could!
Oh my god.
Wait a minute.
This guy is fucking insane.
Actually.
There's lots of things.
Holy shit.
This guy's actually fucking...
Um...
Guys, I think he's gun cage.
I...
All right, let me put...
Guys, I think it's over.
I think this page might be...
Ooh, this page might be a little strut.
Just a little bit.
Yeah, she might be the main character right now.
Honestly, am I...
No, I'm not under farmed at all.
Our Yamato's fucked up, though.
honestly our Yamato was begging for help really we all just
watched it we're like it'll be okay Yamato no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no I shall no longer
roam I don't want oh my I saw it I saw it Get out of here.
You think they'll be able to kill her?
I know you'll help me.
Oh, God.
Is she able to kill her?
Okay, so.
They're Victor, me.
Okay.
I would be able.
Surely.
Oh, my God.
We did it.
We're heroes.
Fucking heroes!
They're gonna remember our names!
Yeah, I'm gonna go for back to base.
It ain't over till it's over!
Our last is fucking dead.
It might be over for him though.
I need a clear green up.
The evil has been defeated.
Oh, we secured Rift, too.
I have my help out here.
Um...
Don't be a jerk.
They took out...
Okay, where's my team?
Oh my god.
Tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock.
Oh my god, where did my health go?
Okay, all right, I live to tell another tale.
Wait, there is it.
See, Paige.
She is so hungry.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, at least we got that out.
I got knocked down at least for it.
Who did I- oh for the dynamo.
I was like, for who?
I'll go blue.
my god they don't even need bro they're like their own rems
all right well you be fine i need you to go up so i can help
oh i hope he doesn't aim up i hope oh there it is I mean,
okay.
I'm just like, I hope he doesn't die anymore.
Holy fuck.
All right.
All
right.
All right.
He's still in there?
Holy fuck.
Green is good!
What are you feeling?
I deserve it!
Bro,
our Yamato is so...
Never again.
Never again will that help.
I don't know what our Yamato is doing.
Why would you go back?
You're so underfed.
Why did he go back?
At least we killed him.
Oh.
Wait, is he?
Oh, why?
I didn't even notice what he is.
Why the fuck did he go back?
What is wrong with him?
We were doing a-okay.
He is so malnourished right now.
He really is.
Oh my god, dude.
I swear to God if I come back.
I'm scared for him.
I'm going to fucking heal him a little bit just in case.
Oh my god, we finally got the Guardian for the first time
there.
Okay, I can get Rapid Reach.
Wait, did I healing Bane after?
11 deaths in 17.
Yeah, I mean, but he was...
He did feed the page a lot.
Oh, there we go.
Get ready for 012.
Get ready.
It's almost there.
Please slam it.
Oh my god, he slammed it there.
That's not expecting that slam.
Not gonna last.
Get him out of here.
Someone get slowing hex right now.
Not me, though.
Someone do it, but I won't.
Alright.
Okay, let's see.
We're slowing Hex.
Do it after.
You're in this way.
There's someone else!
Finding it yellow.
Alright.
Not me!
Again!
Let us go!
Okay.
Surely someone else would do it.
That's not me.
Go!
Yeah, we're in that, huh?
That's right.
Yes.
Oh my god.
Guys, um...
Just don't let them do this to me.
Goodbye.
Why is she literally ripped?
Someone else should really be the support on this team.
I know, right?
Why is no one buying Slow Weex?
I don't understand.
But not me.
Not me, though.
Thank you.
I know, right?
of the team.
People don't count.
I know!
Why does no one counter-buy in this Evo?
See, I know exactly what I should buy.
What the fuck?
No, they're all below me, and I'm scared.
Oh, I could have stolen that.
I got really scared, though.
uh guys they have the rejuvenator they sure do i'm gonna go
steal their sin oh my god yamato please yamato
oh my god yamato please oh i'm scared oh my god why is there
oh my rash wanted to try and get the lat the i mean we're
almost all there
Do I have enough money now?
No.
I see Paige.
Why we don't...
We shouldn't really do any...
Wait, wait.
Bye.
I hear she's still...
He's still going at... Yeah!
Goodbye, Paradox.
Oh, good bye.
Oh.
Bye me, goodbye me.
Not me!
Oh my god!
Get me out of here!
Okay, we got somebody.
Oh, that's...
No, that is so bad for me.
I don't have to, though.
Are you serious?
All right, it's five.
Is there anyone I haven't gone to?
Oh, no, my God.
Okay, that got a little scared.
Someone quick, get slow in hex, but not me.
Oh,
no, not Bonkai.
Not Bonkai.
I won't let you down here.
I'm not Bonkai.
Oh my god, did she survive?
See, it looked cool for a bit.
And call an ambulance, please.
Oh, holy shit.
Why?
Where is my slowing eggs?
Guys, guys, guys, don't worry.
My late game is going to activate soon.
Yeah, alright, fine.
Fine.
I guess...
I will be forced to buy slowing hex because no one else
wanted to be my slowing hex.
I guess I will do the dirty work.
Oh my god.
Fine.
I guess I'll buy the slowing hex.
Oh my god.
Are you Amato?
Where is he?
How do I buy... I can't even...
I don't even see him!
Oh, just when I buy Slowing Hex, he all... he disappears?
He knows.
He fucking knows I have Slowing Hex, too.
He knows I have it now.
He fucking knows.
Time to break open the piggyback and buy something.
Now I can, now I can buy healing temple.
Hey, hey.
Yamato and Mirage?
They're not doing their jobs.
They should buy slowing hex.
They should be buying it.
Because they're not doing the jobs correctly.
They might as well.
They need it more than me.
They might as well play support.
Oh, he's doing the...
That's all I'm gonna say.
If anything.
Should we try the Rift or...
I mean, I'm heading over.
Little guy's heading over.
Oh, nice, we got it.
Don't worry.
A little rem that coulda's heading over now.
Don't worry, don't worry!
I see him!
I got Stowing Eggs!
I got it just for you!
I see him!
I see you!
I got you!
Yeah, what are you gonna do?
Now!
I did it.
That is the key, right?
What are you gonna do?
Okay, I need you to head to the team so I can...
Push it.
I got you!
I got slowly hex!
I can freeze.
I'm not stuck here.
I'll kill you specifically.
Okay, never mind.
I keep forgetting he can do that.
I...
I'm like, what the fuck?
No, he's like, wouldn't he funny if I did it a second time?
That's stupid fucking Apollo.
Doki doesn't learn from her.
I don't.
I didn't learn.
At least he didn't solo at me this time.
At least.
It's okay.
I have slowing hex, guys.
I have slowing hex.
Don't worry.
Slowing hex is coming in play.
The slowing hex is coming in play.
Oh, no.
Well, it's gonna be me and Mirage because I don't know if
our paradox is gonna...
Never mind, it's gonna be me and Mirage, which is a little
concerning.
Don't worry, I'm slowing!
Let's go!
Oh!
nothing to fear from me all i'm saying if we bought slowing
hex things would have been fine wait we did wait what wait
there's like three slowing hexes okay that's not uh me at
that point
yeah i think maybe green i think uh there's an avoid system
i'm avoiding that yamana
What was that Yamada doing?
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
See, I told you it was not me.
Guys, it's not my fault.
Did I somehow...
Oh my god.
What is our Mirage doing?
I somehow did more damage than our Mirage.
I was equal damage with our Yamada.
My damage was on my pillow, too.
It's never my fault.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
Oh.
No.
Okay, I'm banning.
When I want to ban?
Oh, yeah.
Fruit fly.
Where's Fruit fly?
Where is she?
There she is.
No.
There we go.
So, you gotta ban the Fruit fly.
Mandated loss, exactly.
I'm not gonna lose to a fucking fruit plot.
There's 800 items sold to build, but you probably didn't
have to go.
Oh, there is.
There is.
Opening rounds.
I was gonna say, it takes so long.
Oh, there's only a thousand six hundred.
Liar.
There's no other...
Opening rounds.
What are you talking about?
Alan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's high velocity.
Liar.
Okay, it's this.
Alright.
I will try it.
I'll add...
High velocity.
I don't want to add that in.
Oh, high velocity.
Put that here.
and then
all right we'll try that when will the light exactly when
will okay let me actually read what this says deal
additional when in close range ah ah you see why does this
red fail hey it works it works
all right this is This build works.
Add opening rounds?
Where do I add it to?
Alright, we'll get rid of this.
And then...
How do I delete it?
Oh, there you go.
Save.
And then what?
What do I do after?
Opening...
Oh!
Opening rounds.
Okay.
It's red.
Where's opening rounds?
Where is it?
I'm going to Google it.
Opening rounds.
Where do I put opening rounds, though?
Guys.
Where do I put it?
When is it a good time for opening rounds?
Tier 2?
When is it good time?
Where should I put it in between?
between after high velocity here 1600 all right all right
after mystic okay after mystic or or after velocity or meta
or theory crafting now I'll do chat field second or I'll do
after mystic I'll do that all right we'll do chat build chat
build oh you guys know you can practice uh door man stuff
but not not this one you have to go to sandbox but you can't
do a sandbox wait actually let me double check i don't know
if it shows anything right f1 oh not f1 sorry f7 will i show
any of my information that's what i worry about the most if
i press f7 no does it show show any of my info.
Yeah, you can no clip.
I do F7, and then you no clip.
Let me.
Wee!
And then there's a... There's a... Oh my god.
You can't do it here, but you have to...
Wow, wow!
You have to do your...
You can do it in the sandbox, and then you can practice the
doorman stuff, but I can't do it when you're... You can't do
it in the lobby, but you can see the loading screen.
Look at that.
Wee!
Look at that dispute.
Come go to the light.
Rem.
Go to the light.
It comes for you, Rem.
Guys, you're not good to the light.
You're not, Rem.
I actually never went to the light before.
I never been.
Guys, do not go to the light.
Apparently, the light didn't...
That's the first time I've ever went towards the light,
guys.
Do not go to the light.
Apparently, the light answered that.
He naps forever now.
Oh, yes.
There's the...
There's the ghost birds.
Yeah.
Is that cool?
That's so cool.
and explore it.
The lights say, don't do it.
There's like a lot of hidden Easter eggs, too, by no
clipping.
And we know the, you can see the, oh, no, that's the news.
We're smiling.
Oh, there it is.
Do not go turn back.
Turn back.
Yeah.
Wham, wham, wham, wham, wham, wham, I love wham.
Yippee.
Rem 100% success rate, guys.
100% success rate on Rem.
Today's a good day.
Today really is a good day, everyone.
Okay, I requested.
Surely he'll swap with me.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
It's on Yamato now.
Now he's like, I'll show you how to play Yamato.
I really thought.
Exactly.
I'm a team player.
If we lose, it's not my fault.
What else can I do for my team?
So that's my duo.
I did do Remlock, and it was...
Check out the last stream, and you want to see how Remlock
came.
How...
No, not him.
Not Twista.
Okay.
Oh my god, please get that.
I can't do it.
He's looking at me.
Cryptor's looking at me right now.
I like candy.
Or they're great at shuffleboard.
Alright.
Oh my god, he's gonna TP me to me.
He's gonna TP to me.
I'm going in here.
Can't TP me to where I'm next to my safe space.
My safe space.
Okay, I gotta play less aggro.
Oh!
Oh my god, not Twister.
I'm gonna play less aggro.
It might have been a mistake.
Oh, I didn't want him to have it.
I'll be over here.
I need to remember that drifter.
You don't want to be near him.
He hurts.
He hurts, guys.
He hurts so bad.
I don't know if he's gonna live.
I think so.
I didn't give him, like, spear or is this, but...
It was a little bit of a waste.
I don't know.
I feel like it was a little bit of a waste, but what can I
do about it?
Oh, my God.
These guys do so much damage, though.
No!
That should have been mine!
My pillow, I need the cooldown!
Okay, wouldn't it be funny if we died to these mods?
That'll be pretty funny!
Okay, that's...
He's a little crazy for going up there.
Nice.
Don't have Q yet.
Ow.
Good.
Grab this, though.
One more.
I almost got it.
I got him?
I don't know him.
I want to body block!
I did body block.
I did body block, guys.
I did try.
Don't say I didn't try to body block.
It's okay.
I'm next to him.
There's no way.
Oh, he's going to TP to me.
I'm next to him.
Okay, now I have...
I have...
Alright.
Alright, but I would have got that kill, though.
I would have got that kill.
It was literally lined up for it.
That would have been my pillow kill.
100%.
He just killed him too fast.
Like, what the fuck was I supposed to do?
It's not my fault you killed him so fast
He's so low He's actually what I can heal too Alright
Yeah it's my duel Alright I'm getting all the duos out the
way before I cry in solo queue.
Before I get yelled at.
Wait, oh, I thought it was greed time.
Really?
Aw, that shot should have went through.
That shot should have gone through.
Come on.
Oh my god, this slowed down.
Wait, I hear someone.
Alright.
I'm a little scared.
I'm gonna...
Greed, greed, greed, greed.
Greed time, greed time.
Greed!
Oh, me come back.
Me come back.
Me stop being greedy.
Don't worry.
Boom!
My kill.
She sure does, Rem.
She sure does.
Is McGinnis okay?
Or is our McGinnis?
Is he okay?
No.
Damn, sorry.
I hope he's okay.
Wherever he's going through.
I don't know what happened, but I hope he's okay.
I'm asleep.
I can sleep him.
Guys.
Yeah, TPing me to me right now.
That's wrecking, right?
You won't.
I dare you.
That's right.
TPing me right now, bitch.
I bet you won't.
That's right.
I'm calling her bluff.
I'm mad.
Come on, TPing me.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, I know you won't.
I know you're scared.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right!
That's what you get!
You ain't touching me!
The baby fights back!
Wait, it's my teammate okay?
I gotta...
Uh...
What the fuck?
He wants to kill me?
I'm just gonna close my eyes for a second.
Oh, he's sinners in 30, you're so right.
You're so right, you're so right.
I gotta keep my Oh.
Oh, I thought that would hit him.
I'm getting ready.
It's sinners time.
It's almost sinners time.
Oh, sinners, sinners, sinners.
I'm gonna go.
Goodbye.
Rita's good.
Wait.
Okay, but I...
I can also grab this, though.
He'll be fine.
I'm looking at my Yamato's HP And he's so healthy Once in
there, stolen I told you I told you it'll be fine Not
through the left side But I didn't get it
Okay, I gotta help him Alright I did?
Nice Oh, I did
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's five.
Oh my god, he's so healthy.
Look at that.
He was so healthy.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
I'm dodging lasers.
I'm Tom Cruise.
What about the Scientology part?
is so nice I hope you are full to fight me good save thank
you thank you just gotta be clarify that you know gotta make
sure everyone knows I'm like him but like not like the other
parts about him I'm gonna do the doubles you
know why I was going crazy because of my insane support
You're welcome.
I'm gonna steal that.
Yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum.
They do lots of things.
Yum, yum, yum.
Yay!
Yippee!
I'm gonna heal them for a bit.
Just so you guys a little bit more healing.
Greed, Greed, Greed, Greed, Greed, Greed.
Greed, Greed, Greed, Greed, Greed.
I'll go help Greed.
Greed, Greed.
Greed is good.
Me help.
Yeah, I see Twifta.
Oh, I need a vibe.
See Abram!
Alright.
What the fuck?
Wait, I'm bad Graves!
Not here!
What do you mean?
Why is the fruit fly?
Oh shit, they got blue.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh wait, he's got blue, he's got blood, go back.
Let me read a little bit.
Okay, I got one of them, so I'm backing out a little bit.
You should be fine, right?
I'll give you extra heals.
Is there game lock?
No, it's just I can't stream this game on higher FPS.
But you guys don't notice it, right?
Luckily, because I'm playing Rem, it doesn't matter that
much.
I just can't stream this game higher than it for some
reason.
No, we...
No, goddammit!
Yeah, like, luckily, because it's REM, it doesn't really
matter.
Oh my gosh.
I mean, sure?
Oh, please!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, they got it.
Doesn't matter.
We're two of them.
they're coming i don't think we can save that
okay i'll put that in there
all right i'm using it by i don't i've auto cast there so i
don't know if it works i'm gonna try let's try it out grave
yellow bitch you're so stupid
The barrel's rusted.
My hero.
Headed to Greenwich.
That's right.
Get baited.
I knew my mom was gonna pick me up.
I...
I mean, that's right.
My mom picked me up from the store.
Yeah, I said, yeah, that's it.
Get baited.
I knew exactly that she was going to pick me up.
You yellow?
That's a king red.
Yeah!
Oh, I thought he was going to be there.
They're gonna get yellow.
I don't think we can do anything about that.
I think we can enforce this honestly.
Moms here!
Hey shit, Moms here!
I'll follow my mom around.
Holy shit, my movement.
Mom's coming to shape me.
Mom, mom, mom.
what the fuck okay that should honestly oh nice we got that
i'll help i'll heal her a little bit no go back go back go
back i need to go to mom i don't like doing confirmed cats
because oh nice i got that stack for free i'm just getting
warmed up uh green and then you don't oh yeah oh yeah
It's like I always fuck up and confirm.
That's just, oh my god.
That's just a me issue though.
That's a me issue.
Here we go.
I got it though.
Oh shit.
I walked into that.
I really did.
Oh, I should have left it.
him to die.
Why did I do that?
God damn fly.
Everything I banned doesn't get banned.
What's the point?
What's the fuck is the point?
Oh, seal time.
Seal seal.
Wait, actually?
No, that's not.
Do I need five more?
No, I'm good.
I'm so healthy.
I'll grab this, though.
See, older M would have stolen that, too.
I still want to, though.
I do want to steal it.
I should have shot in the middle.
There you go.
Do I have enough?
No, I need 4K.
Mom!
Mom, I got you!
Thank you.
Mom!
I
don't want to buy something new.
Hurry, Mom!
Mom came back to see- I got myself in trouble.
I don't think I was- I don't- Okay, I got this little
paranoid.
I- I had to- I had to look down and see if there's a fucking
Abrams hiding against.
Our Yamato's dead.
Don't you know what?
Unless the Yamato can kill one person with...
Oh, Yamato, can you get to me?
Alright, rescue beam.
Alright.
Holy shit.
I have enough, actually.
Nice.
Alright, secured.
I did my job.
Why did you not get that bad?
Guys, I did my job.
Took you, dude.
I did my job.
I see.
What kind of item should I buy?
Oh.
You can get slowing hacks for the for the dynamo.
I don't.
I think the Billy thought I was going to come with him.
I think the Billy man I thought I was going to I was going
to be there with him.
I'm sorry, I'll leave her.
That's a little awkward.
Um...
I got my one.
Wait.
I creep, creep, creep, creep.
I'm creep, creep, creep, creep, creep, creep, creep, creep,
creep.
That's true.
Don't try a little green for Yama.
I don't think he knows.
If I...
Yeah!
I got it.
I see Drifter.
I just grabbed it.
Just grabbed it.
It's fine.
I got it.
Oh, shit.
Blue.
Yeah, you don't have to save it for people.
If you aren't it, I mean, your character likes it too, so
you can use it on you.
Okay.
Wait, I need a bad knockdown.
Uh, I'll buy it here.
I see dynamo.
I like naps.
All right, I had to go back to yellow.
Oh, you guys.
Yeah, I saw it.
Blame yourself.
It's never my fault.
It's a team game.
In fact, in fact, it should be like...
Oh my god.
What's wrong with you?
Oh my god, where are my other stuff?
Alright, there we go.
Shirley's not there, right?
Where'd my new friend go?
Drifter 1.
I'm going over.
Wait, I'll clear this wave and now coming over.
I'm coming over, guys!
Don't worry, the child's here!
RIM, RIM, RIM, RIM, RIM, RIM!
Rem rem rem rem rem rem rem the child's here to save the day
don't worry everyone I'm here where's everyone guys where is
everyone where is everyone go
doing like 900 watch out all right i'm gonna go help i'm
gonna help mom mom i'm here to take your fire what you
wanted don't worry man i took your fire so we can both be
fed greedy ass child so it happens
Well, I'll go help.
Wait, there's dynamo.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, that is good.
I didn't hit that?
Oh, come on.
That should have been a hit.
Oh, my God.
I didn't hit that out of there.
That's it.
I'm angry.
I'm stealing their doubles.
Oh, my God.
I can hear their footsteps.
I'm not stealing their doubles.
I...
I- oh god I hear them walking behind me.
Now I'm stealing their doubles.
Now I do it.
Ah!
Mom!
Okay, fuck that guy in particular.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
Look at that.
Easy!
Die begins!
What do you mean?
There we go.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
we're good you guys nothing to worry about nothing to worry
about can I shoot those graves oh my god he's coming over oh
my god that guy definitely has all I knew it guys what does
proc mean wait I can steal that Oh, graves are heavy, melee.
No idea.
They're great at shuffleboard.
It's okay.
All right.
I'll just be here.
But I can buy stuff.
I'll do the tunnels here.
But I can see that.
Okay.
all right oh i think he's grabbing it wait he's grabbing our
sinners hey you're not red wait i gotta spend this first
before i go over there and steal
all right here we go i don't procs on abilities ah dynamo
green or blue sorry green i will go this way come and rip
though oh that looks so juicy though That looks so juicy
over there.
Oh my god.
That one sinner on the top left.
That one Abram?
Color.
Thank you for this.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Your blade drinks the blood of the guided hand.
Serious.
Might as well.
Roofly.
Roofly is here.
I'm worried about the dynamo so I'm gonna wait a little I'm
not gonna try anything yet don't don't use it at best I can
kill you don't worry mom I got you so true oh it wouldn't be
sick if I got the sniper though that that was I've been so
sick.
I'm so scared of the dynamo right now.
I don't want to.
Oh, I swear to God, if I get dynamo off of here, I swear to
God, if I get dynamo off of here.
I swear to God.
Alright, what is he holding his dynamo up for?
3-1 mid.
I don't even know what he's holding it for.
What did we do a shrine, guys?
But what did we do a shrine?
What did we do a shrine?
What did we do?
One shrine.
What did we do a shrine?
What did we do two shrines?
All right, nice.
Just get one shrine and then do mid.
Oh, oh, wait.
That's not the shrine.
What did we...
We just tried.
That's a guardian.
I got a little confused.
I got spirit, though.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I saw that.
Okay, now.
What do we do mid-bust?
Yeah.
Bee.
Wait, wait, wait.
Sinner, sinner, sinner.
There's that one sinner.
over there okay i got it what if i do doubles though i have
a bit confused what i got exactly i got birds oh my god look
at that they're that double juicy doubles i'm so hungry oh
feed me this little chud wants to be a big chud i'm yum yum
yum yum
Yes!
Big child!
Mom!
You're not mom.
There's mom.
Mom's over there.
Mom!
Mom on here!
How do you, like, not get hit by that?
How do you not get hit by the line, thingy?
You think he'll be okay?
Where is everybody?
Alright, there you go.
I couldn't see anyone, I'm so lost.
No!
That's the one time I didn't save it!
There it was!
In 20 years he finally died!
use it oh my god they got led in the false sense of security
the false it got me the false sense of security he's got me
i would what do i sell this opening rounds i feel like no if
i sell what do i sell for scourge It was indeed the cosmos.
He finally figured it out.
I know, but like, when I can afford it, what do I sell for
it?
Opening?
I can catch a green here.
And then he'll get opening rounds and then he'll be in.
All right.
Abram's green.
Abram is green.
Don't worry.
Got you.
Two supports.
Two supports can kill an Abrams.
Boom.
But he's on our shit.
Thank you.
Get out of here!
No!
He still got it!
God damn it.
Oh wait, there's a dynamo here too.
Well, we know dynamo doesn't have refresher, so.
Ow.
God damn it.
Avery's blue.
Because of all the times I've stolen it.
There's three blue.
There sure is.
Oh my god, he was petrified on me, though.
He was petrified on me.
It's a worthy exchange.
Equivalent exchange.
Equivalent exchange, everyone.
It was worth it.
It was 100% worth it.
I take those.
To be honest, one little guy.
It was one little guy.
Viscous, your team is grateful for the work you've been
doing.
I take those.
Dynamo's missing.
Oh, they didn't refresh it.
Are we doing min?
Alright.
Item occurs.
Is he?
Disarmed.
Okay, that was very smart.
That was actually a crazy jump.
I'm scared.
It's five.
Everything is five.
everything is gonna be five all right see see that if that
vipers saved her up oh god oh god the dynamo has oh god the
dynamo has held i repeat the dynamo has up vipers disarmed
okay i'm ready i'm ready for it i'm ready for the dynamo
what the fuck it hits something would have I am I'm ready I
have oh my god where's the dynamo where the fuck is I got
you I got you what do you mean
He actually bought Refresher!
There's no way.
He actually bought Refresher.
He didn't buy Refresher all the other times!
The Refresher that was promised 3,000 years ago.
I was like, what do you mean there's a second?
It took him...
End game.
Don't worry.
Refresher is late build.
Refresher is late build, guys.
All right, this is my least damage game though.
I was, I felt like I was, I was definitely fucking around
though too much.
He wanted to, who would have thought?
Refresher is late build.
A second dynamo has entered the bit all right see guys i'm
doing it okay wait let me write this down okay so how do i
edit this i understand how did why can i edit this little
chat thing hello let me type
how to type it
how do i type this oh here okay so all right guys sell what
do we sell hi and then what else after heal pain and then
what else after heal bay i'm doing it i'm building i'm build
i'm i'm building well technically you guys are doing it for
me help heal pain enchanter what have you okay all right
save all right there you go i'm doing i'm so smart i'm such
a smart little guy i really am i'm rim
i did it guys let me go
oh you're right i should buy egg next time
Golden egg.
Wait, let's see.
I'm going to use the bathroom, guys.
I'll be right back.
Should I do the 30-minute egg?
Next game.
We do the 30-minute golden egg.
Guys, we're late game.
True late game rem build.
30-minute egg.
Buy a trophy in golden dress.
Wait, which one's cultist?
uh do i have cultists in my cultist sacrifice uh target mpc
consumer for grants powerful oh my god wait wait okay or do
i have cultists in here i don't okay it was an egg cultist
all right let's try let's try it okay um edit egg uh you
don't really need cultists okay what What's an egg?
What do we need?
The greed build.
Never sell egg at 30.
Then buy another.
Is that how the egg works?
Okay.
Hatch the...
How do I...
I just need to hatch it.
The value goes the longer you hold on to it.
Minus 10% damage penalty.
Alright.
Egg plus trophy collector.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm going to be so fast.
fast.
I already have trophy collector here.
Alright, we'll do that.
We'll do egg building.
Okay, I'm gonna...
If we do that, I need to do this so I don't... So I have
enough money for egg.
Egg.
Do I buy trophy after egg?
Do I just save...
Or like, do I save it up for it?
Or do I, like, can I buy other stuff?
one of best doorman players so he's on the list
what about what about uh trophy collector when do i buy a
trophy collector after
he's the reason the list exists exactly okay i would say i
will say i think doorman is peak sexy tumbler man I think if
Dorman came out during peak Tumblr, he would have one, he
would have so many fans and fan art.
He literally, he literally looks like peak Loki during peak
Tumblr's sexy man time, but ginger.
Stop.
I think he, he would have been, he would have been a sexy
Tumblr man.
He is a Tumblr man.
a shiny low-key variant, exactly.
I hate that cheeser, right?
He literally is made to be a sexy tumbler man.
Look, Jerma exists as a sexy tumbler, Wikipedia.
So, um, so it only makes sense that Dorman would also be a
sexy tumbler man.
Big velocity rounds, mystic.
first.
A trophy collect.
Oh, I need opening.
Okay, okay.
Trophy collector after.
So I need this here.
So trophy collector after opening rounds.
I actually haven't watched any.
The only deadlock stream I watch is my friend Shurifwe.
But he doesn't play REM.
So, I mean, sometimes I would see him fucking do gun REM.
But, um, I haven't actually watched any deadlock streams
yet.
I won't watch a REM streamer.
Because I learn the best uh watching an actual streamer play
because i just regurgitate whatever they do i just try to
emulate what they do but i think i've improved a lot though
i think i personally think i improved a lot um on rem like
i've been speed running like this is like two weeks of
deadlock ending i feel like i don't i don't know i feel like
i'm getting better with only two weeks of deadlock
two weeks of deadlock i think i'm getting a lot better look
at that um i'm like 50 oh my 30 look at like 35 than that i
have less games on ivy and i'm more than not yeah what's my
pair i don't i never parry and i never melee look one at a
time i have to learn i'm learning mechanics one at a
Each mechanic I learn one by one.
Look, I got the...
I'm slowly getting the tunnels mechanic.
One thing at a time, guys.
One at a time.
We'll figure out Perry later.
Wham!
Yay, today's a lucky rem day.
Today's a lucky rem day for me.
Because I keep getting rem.
I think next game we'll do one rank game and then we'll call
it.
We'll do one rank game.
next game and then we'll see how people let's we'll see how
it goes i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared i'm really scared
dormant apollo lies apollo deserves to be with the fruit fly
they're they're match made in heaven
Swap with me, bitch!
Oh, wait.
Let's hope and I are rescind my DM.
No, I have every character in Locker.
Not every.
I have, like, all the characters.
I already have 15 wins on Ivy, Rem, and 7.
So I'm fine.
Damn.
Wait, is B-pop?
No, I have Victor and Kevin, the other ginger, the bear
ginger, the barra ginger.
We have gingers of all shapes and sizes and orientation.
Oh, don't worry.
Oh, he ain't ready for my egg buy.
Oh, I should have used my...
Okay, who did- how do we already have a Denyagon?
It's not my fault.
Every flavor of ginger.
My thing is so slow.
Hold my duos, okay.
I'm not looking at him.
Ah.
Where did my little guy even go to?
Wait, I purchased- You bought an item!
No!
I fucked it up!
I don't have, I can't do golden egg.
My little guy bought an item.
I didn't even look at it.
You think I still do the build?
Guys, you think I can still do the build, guys?
Okay, we still buy it.
We just don't get as much.
Unintentioned.
What a hero.
My little...
They're like, yeah, I bought a fucking item.
Um.
Okay.
Sell that now and buy the egg.
You're so right.
Give me a sec.
Let me sell that.
You're so right.
Let me...
Don't worry.
Just hold the egg longer to compensate.
All right, now we can queue build.
All right, now we can queue it.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We got this.
We got egg now.
Guys, 30 minutes, 30 minutes.
No, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Don't make me eat my egg.
I'll do it.
It's like I start inking by eating my egg.
it oh
no we're gonna denies a lot oh
no he's weak he's
so heavily invested don't worry
okay we're five yeah i can finally buy other items all right
Oh, what the fuck?
I don't mean to do that.
I'm helpful.
I am.
I'm so helpful.
Oh, no.
Okay, then guys.
No, don't deny it.
Okay, you didn't deny it.
I'm so helpful.
And not...
Oh, my God.
They ran away.
I'm just gonna do that real quick.
Just heal it fully.
I'm still helpful.
All right, don't worry.
We're five.
I got victory.
It did nothing, but I got victory.
Ow!
Everything's okay.
All right.
I'm gonna play with me.
Yeah.
Okay, nice.
Oh, goddammit, I didn't hit those.
Wait, where's my...
Where's my helper?
Wait, I'm by myself.
No.
Oh, my gosh, I'm by myself in my lane.
Everything will be fine.
Everything...
Whoa!
Stolen?
wait I'll grab this oh my gosh the stocks going up though
stocks are going up
it's okay there you go I got it oh my god I see the money I
see all that money going up 30 minutes 30 minutes coming in
the 30 minute the scaling here.
Don't worry.
10 more minutes to go.
Alright.
I can...
Okay.
The thing is, I have to ult him when he goes into the ice
dome.
I feel that.
Ow!
I feel that would make more sense if I wait until the ice
dome starts hitting.
It's fine.
I gotta go in.
Oh!
What did that guy come from?
Did I eat the egg?
I did!
I asked, I thought it was...
Oh, big happens.
I...
I saw
the...
I ate it on...
Wait, can I buy the egg again?
Okay.
I thought...
It's over.
We lost the egg.
The build is over.
We can recover from this.
I just need to eat the egg again.
I just need to buy another egg, right?
Oh, he's in there.
He's in there.
We need all the option.
I fell down.
I fell down the hole.
I never financially recover from this.
I hate the egg.
I saw the two egg build would go crazy, though, Dirty.
Do I do it?
Do I buy two eggs?
Is that this trap?
What if I buy a second egg?
Guys.
Guys, but what if I'm not finishing this camp?
Like, yeah, I'm just...
Oh, come on!
Oh my god, wait, that guy's low.
Oh my god.
Hey!
I sold, no!
I sold before we could make it big!
What is under attack?
Then early years, what was she cooking?
It's now, or you're right.
You're right, Dwight, I'm doing it.
I'm going to buy another egg.
You're right.
But what if...
We can do this again.
I didn't even make back my money from the egg.
Okay, just...
Just don't end.
Just just don't end.
It's just that easy as luck.
Oh my god, Joufna's here.
Joufna.
I go.
We lose that.
Just don't eat.
Don't worry.
They're in 20.
Go buy the curiosity shoppy.
It'll be fine As long as I don't eat it it'll be fine It's
just cuz I saw B I saw B pop and I I Rethink you see because
I thought it was my knock down for some reason Can I go back
Okay, I know what to do guys I know what to do
I love it
Uh...
Oh my god, I'm trying to unbind it.
I'm trying to unbind Z.
No.
If I unbind Z, I wouldn't accidentally use it.
Guys, how do I unbind an item?
Oh, it's shaking me.
What the fuck?
No, you don't understand.
It makes more sense.
if I unbind it it really does make more sense guys if I
unbind the item so I won't ink oh you're so right you're so
right there's no way I can touch it now
is there even Yamato I'm gonna help our Yamato actually oh
there's rift yeah Um, good luck Yamato.
Let me go Rift.
Me and Kevin both go Rift.
I think it should be 5.
I got Paige.
Oh, we lost Rift!
No!
It's 5?
Alright, we're 5.
Oh, not a Yamato, though.
I don't know what a Yamato is doing.
Or a Yamato's just having a fun time, I think.
Holy shit, I...
Yeah.
Um, we don't have anything right now.
I'm a little scared.
Alright, here we go.
I couldn't kill everybody a little bit more.
one.
Here we go.
Oh, that should have hit.
I mean, she's alive.
At least.
Oh, they're sinners.
Yeah, at least I can eat a little bit.
Greed ish blood.
I hear someone behind me.
Here we go.
I got it.
I hit her.
Wait.
We'll be okay.
That'll be fine.
He's gonna be so healthy.
Oh my god.
He's so healthy.
Oh.
I leave.
Maybe I'll hit something.
Okay.
Why did he still die?
What were you doing?
Our yellow walker is under attack.
Yeah.
You can buy that.
Why?
No, why did he go back?
He'll help our Apollo.
Thank you.
Alright.
Oh.
What?
What's going on over there?
I left you guys for three seconds.
Coming over.
I'm going to steal.
Oh, I was going to steal that because I thought I was a good
little boy.
That deserves the sinners.
Because I'm so hungry.
I'm so hungry.
I'm going to help green.
Is anybody?
Nobody is technically under five or anything.
We're all like pretty equal.
Back over here.
Ha ha ha!
That's Toby!
Wait, I grabbed that.
Wait, I can grab this too.
So hungry.
I'm so hungry.
Okay, I need to do tunnels now.
Oh, shit.
Wait, the 7's here.
Get out of here!
Oh, you're so lucky.
Don't get rid of these guys.
You're so lucky!
I was supposed to be doing my tunnels!
Alright, don't worry.
I'll head over.
Nice.
Here I go.
Alright.
Tunnels, tunnels, tunnels.
Oh, should I help the Yamato?
I'm not gonna go over there.
Let me...
Let me walk.
What can I buy now?
Oh,
that's the big story.
Don't worry, I'm helping.
I'm lost.
Where am I?
Where did I end up going?
Oh, more yummy.
More boxes.
I went the wrong way.
Not a mid-boss.
Oh, do I even...
Is this even worth coming over?
I'm doing it.
I'm not doing it.
My bag is so big.
I got lost.
Yes!
Take me out of
here!
I got him alive.
What?
I don't see.
It was worth it.
I distracted him.
him long enough.
I'll go to green.
We actually know I'll go yellow.
Yamato's gotten every pun.
That's a great escape.
That's true.
And I kept my shit too.
I kept everything, guys.
I gotta keep on it up.
Wait, wait.
Ah!
It's okay, but didn't get the one way back.
They didn't get the way to our Apologo!
Oh my god.
I fucked up.
I should have followed our Apologo.
I didn't realize he was being chased.
I didn't realize Apollo was being chased, guys.
I got jumped in an alleyway.
I really did.
I thought I was so, I'm gonna steal sinners on green,
because they're all on yellow, so that means I can do it.
I'm Ram!
Ram!
Surely I could steal this, sir.
I'll be fine.
You help me, help me, help me.
I'm coming over.
My feet.
You kind of got yourself caught out there.
Yeah, it could be like that.
He's coming.
all right it's okay oh my god oh it's okay I don't have oh
my god please I'm so scared everyone it's
fine Or is he gonna be fine?
He's got this.
I got stacks.
We don't need to care about green.
Who cares about green?
Oh my god, I gotta help you, though.
Fun time!
Oh my god.
Guys,
kids, we're almost at a 30-minute mark.
for sure though by after healing tempo yeah holy shit the
drifter where did he come from for the for the drifter oh
yeah I could do that yeah oh I guess I guess on my knockdown
I guess I guess 20 minutes you're right you're right 40
minutes surely surely don't worry we're gonna make it we're
gonna play this game this game will last another 20 minutes
guys i believe oh yeah wait did i knock them down i i don't
know i can't tell if it knocked them down or not
oh Oh, guys, this is a little awkward.
This is a little awkward.
I'm aiming for this.
Don't worry.
We might have lost all our walkers, and they still have all
their walkers.
But, but, but this, we will make sure this game will...
Don't worry, this game will last another 20 minutes, guys.
Just you wait.
Just you wait, everyone.
Wait and see.
and you get 4k
the more I believe
what the fuck you're still alive just you wait guys it's
gonna happen
it's gonna happen this is oh my god you scared this shit I
thought you was getting chased at or some shit with the with
the leave i see with die leave grip will be green all right
we'll be fine
will they be fine oh oh oh oh oh that's page now too
oh my god oh my god i do see bbop i see page are we not
doing green i guess not oh my god we're actually gonna go
mid okay wait unless oh the surprise ivy thing well not
really a thing
Did you have to hit
anybody?
I swear I...
Oh, they were all in my...
They were all there!
How did that not hit anyone?
Oh my god, and I got hit by that.
And we lost Riff.
I don't understand!
I walked backwards!
Oh, that's on me.
That's on me, guys.
That's...
That's on me.
I didn't realize I walked backwards.
I didn't even realize that.
I thought I was just like, oh, I see everybody.
It's so... Don't worry.
Don't worry.
Ten more minutes.
I should have found S2.
You're right.
Guys, ten more minutes and we'll hit the late game.
Oh, it's so juicy.
Well, we'll have so much to buy.
Don't worry, in 10 minutes, we will, the 40-minute egg,
trust, trust in the 40-minute egg.
The rejuvenator is descending.
It's right here, it's right here, I believe.
Just need, oh wait, I actually, and I'll, okay, 4,800.
It's my bad that I had enough now.
Almost close to it.
Should get it here.
Oh, what the fuck?
These guys are stride.
Okay, from here I should get it then.
There we go.
Alright.
Watch my egg.
My egg's $2,000.
I can feel it.
Why is he...
Guys, guys, he needs to live for 13...
Guys, I need them to live for 10 more minutes so I can get
my...
So I can get my golden egg.
All right.
Get me out of here.
What do you mean?
They have rejuven!
You're fighting, like, against people with rejuvenes.
Exactly.
Oh, wait, he's fighting with people against Riju.
I'm using...
True, true!
Oh, he's fucked.
Wait, I still got it!
I still got it!
It's fucked!
Did he have pressure on his pawn?
What do you mean he has pull again?
A double hook?
He gets two hooks!
You know what do you mean?
That's rough.
God, I have a safe...
It's okay.
I might have to eat my egg.
I might actually have to eat it.
Hey, guys.
I have to eat the egg.
I don't...
I think my team will survive for any minutes.
I think I might have to eat it.
I might have to eat it.
Got it.
Wait, wait, unless, unless...
Hold, hold, hold, hold, hold, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, hold.
There is hope.
Wait, wait.
Hold, hold, hold, hold, hold, hold.
Wait, wait, wait.
It is possible.
Wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute, guys.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
35 minutes.
Guys, 35 minutes.
We'll eat the egg at 35.
Tell it now.
Guys, guys, guys.
35 minutes.
It might be possible.
Pushing yellow.
And I could even... I can even grab this.
Hold.
And I might be able to grab this.
There you go.
Why is the Yamato still there?
tp'd onto us yum two minutes for egg maxing wait i'm gonna
do it three five wait we're almost there we're almost at
three five minutes i can't get to him guys i'm about to eat
it that'd be my second first hopefully this way i'm eating
it i'm eating it i'm eating it i have to eat it i'm eating
it i have to eat it i had to we have to break it open i
can't our father died
it's so delicious though yum yum yum yum yum oh it's so
delicious now make it count little cat this is it power
spike.
We got the power spike now.
No, no, no.
We're late game room.
We've made it.
We've made it to late game room.
It's time to turn this game around.
Om, yum, yum.
Oh my god, I almost went the wrong way.
Okay, what about third egg?
Is there?
You're so right.
I got two.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
I can't, where am I?
Holy shit.
What's damaging me?
What the fuck is damaging me?
You're right, I should buy 30.
You're so right.
Guys, I should have kept Victor bad.
Unfortunately, late game Victor over late game prep.
What
do you mean late game?
Victor is stronger than late game prep.
After everything I've been through, who would have thought
you're 40 minutes?
would have won that you're so right.
You're so right.
We're...
I got too scared.
I was too scared to commit.
Guys.
Oh, no, they're doing mid-boss.
Neh.
It's not fair.
They have both Victor and Driftaw?
Oh my god, from...
Oh my god, what do I even...
It's not fair.
They have Victor end with the...
Okay, but I did troll the build, though.
It's not... It's not...
It's not because I'm not ready for rank.
I am trolling a little bit with my build.
I...
Yeah.
I did troll a bit.
I did buy ink two times.
What the fuck?
Okay, I got scared that somebody was pushing up.
Guys, I don't know anymore if this is winnable.
I'm unsure.
I have a feeling this game might be really, really hard.
Just a feeling, though.
Careful, careful, they're looking.
Where are they looking, though?
I should be fine here.
Okay, duration extender.
Victor has refresher.
There.
No, he does.
Fucking freak.
Yeah, what?
Do I not?
Oh, no.
We don't have slots.
We need one more slot.
Maybe I should buy a third egg.
You're so right.
I know you'll help me.
Maybe I should buy a third egg right now.
Page?
Oh wait, there's three, there's two.
They're all there, they're all there.
I'm scared.
Why does that not hit him?
I swear to God.
Where is he?
I'm sorry.
Don't be a jerk.
There we go!
Okay.
I got one of them!
Oh my god, we got, we got one of them.
Okay, we got it, we got you!
Oh, okay, well, well, that's a victor, so I don't know.
That's a victor, so I don't know, guys.
Will you guys be fine?
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm just gonna do that just just for fun Oh, he's getting
closer
Oh my god, I was nails at the corner Guys, I did guys guys
guys, I'm super late game
Oh my god, guys, I think their victor might be more late
game than me.
There is a chance that their victory is just might be a
little bit more late, please.
I think there might be might be ultra mega late things.
Funcat!
Oh my god, raid boss down!
Raid boss down!
Everyone, raid boss down.
Raid boss down, raid boss down.
There's hope.
The raid bosses got...
He probably...
He probably bought three eggs, guys.
We just didn't know it.
Oh my god.
He probably did.
Fixed base.
I'm gonna get ripped.
It's just for sure.
Okay.
Oh, there's two.
There's two more.
I'll still fight.
I'm fighting it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god, as long as we don't get out.
Where is he?
Okay, he got up.
It's just three.
There they sit.
Are you fucking away?
I hit him.
It says no one ever.
Oh my god, we can grab this.
oh my god wait wait there's hope there's hope guys there
actually might be hope
oh my god we got another slot oh mid mid mid mid mid yeah
yeah let's go mid okay while we go get min got the really
buy two no don't i didn't fucking no i don't have enough
Okay.
Alright.
Mid, mid, mid, mid, mid, mid, mid, mid.
What the fuck was...
Stop fighting, stop fighting.
Okay, okay.
Come on, come on.
Nice.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
There's hope, there's hope, there's hope.
I'm stealing it.
I'm gonna steal.
I'm pretty sure he's still there.
Wait, I can still steal it.
Oh my god, I have so much money.
Okay.
No, I heard someone in the sinners.
That's why I threw it.
I was trying to get him off the sinners so I could steal it,
guys.
Okay, uh, what was it?
What do I buy for?
Okay, sell high.
Wait.
What can I sell it?
Why can't I sell it?
Oh shit, okay.
I'll sell it.
And then...
Oh, opening rounds.
Alright.
Okay, okay, there you go.
We're five.
Okay.
Three bosses down for now.
Holy shit, that guy is tanky.
I know you'll help me.
Alright.
we're gonna i'm gonna go over and help don't worry i'm here
don't worry i'm here
holy shit
get out of here oh my god the victory oh my god not again
not again
Not again Nothing scares me I see people Okay, we got people
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine
Alright, we got it, we got it, we got it, oh shit, I'll go
defend I'll go back and defend It's okay, they don't need
me, they don't need me
I'm going as fast as I can Oh my god there you go
Alright Oh please I'm true Oh my god Oh my fucking poor base
Oh Oh my god, if he gets touch one time, we're so dead!
Oh my god!
Our little beast!
Our little fucking beast!
Okay, enchantment.
Alright.
Made up in a minute, 20.
It's okay, it's regenerating, yeah.
Okay.
Everything is Dijobu.
Careful, Paulo.
Everyone's up.
Rift on yellow.
Okay, we'll fight Rift.
What is wrong with my damage is so low now?
Drift is Drift.
Yeah.
I see the enemy.
He's in our secret shop.
Alright.
Just watch the back door
I'm watching I'm scared Just once she wants the back door
Okay, I'm going over Oh my god, they're back door and
they're one back door.
I'm going over
Oh Yamato, oh Yamato
All right
God is, God is five.
Oh my god, it's the victor.
It's him.
We need to go back.
We need to go back after that kill.
I'm going back now.
I'm flying.
I'm going over.
Follow them.
Okay, nice.
Rip mid here.
Fix this wave and rip mid.
I think Vector's gonna try and back through our med.
I think he's over there right now.
Alright, here we go.
This is so scary.
I'll fix YOLO wave.
Just the doom it, boss.
I'll fix all our wave.
I'm heading over.
Oh, my God.
Are we going in?
Are we going mid?
Page has cheeked up now.
I don't know.
I don't see anybody downstairs yet.
I don't think...
Are you mid?
Mid or no?
All right.
Yeah, let's force mid.
We have to go down.
My damage is so low, guys.
It's a double-shocking kill here.
There we go.
What is my IV doing?
You can shoot through my window and do double the damage.
I did not know that, actually.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Just IV things, I guess.
Oh, the Apollo didn't get it.
Okay, but I could grab this too.
Oh, wait.
Green.
I'll fix it.
Just stay and hold the position.
We're so healthy.
They don't need their sinners, but I do.
They don't need it, but I need it.
I want it, dude.
I want it all.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum.
10k i fucked up my jump i will fix the yellow what's that
going going get krish relics as we can
okay here we go i'm still alive i'm still alive oh oh oh oh
stay alive stay alive All right, that's five.
We're fixing our waves.
I think Apollo is a scary character to play, or to play
against, if they're good at it.
Unfortunately, they're not very good at Apollo.
That's just the unfortunate part.
Oh my god.
We're halfway from our rejuve.
We gotta go for it.
I see the enemy.
I don't
want to use that can't see
Oh my god,
can't see
Oh my god, that picture
Don't let him near me Don't let him touch me All right, it's
fine.
Okay.
Oh my god, I don't think you guys need to get out.
I don't know about her ivy.
Oh no.
Okay.
I don't know if he's okay.
Oh my god.
Please don't let me get grabbed.
I'll heal you for again.
Hold the line!
Oh, that is...
What happened to us?
Please, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What happened to us?
Oh my god.
We held the...
Guys, may or may not have trolled the build a little.
I mean...
But maybe my build was a little too troll.
Maybe...
Because maybe we shouldn't have done that.
Maybe we shouldn't have not have... Maybe we shouldn't have
bought egg twice.
It might have been a terrible terrible idea Maybe a third
egg Maybe I shouldn't have bought the egg twice Guys She was
not you inked too early I should have bought the egg three
times oh yeah maybe i should have cracked the egg at 40
minutes you're so right i couldn't i was so scared oh apollo
died all right do we do it do we rip rink now all right
let's try we're gonna try rink me try one game of rink all
right it's time it's time to get yelled at now
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Imagine I go in.
I don't get rem on my one ranking.
Good morning, good morning, Juki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
I knew I should never have banned.
I knew I should never unban victory.
Oh, wait.
That's standard.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm so used to queuing standard.
абсолютно.
Rink.
There we go.
Um.
Find my purpose.
Alright.
There we go.
Hey sir, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Words of wisdom from Doki.
Hold the line.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lolly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You got this Doki.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I might.
I've been a little tro- Oh, Ben!
I forgot the Ben!
Fuck this guy.
There you go.
I forgot to avoid Victor.
I knew it every- I knew I should have never taken Victor
off.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I should have taken Victor off.
Wee!
We got the Ben.
Should I ask Lime?
Isn't Lime a Remain?
What do we do when we have two?
rems in the party I only play rem I refuse to play anything
else and I say that and I get Ivy I could feel it I could
feel the Ivy calling for me like the fucking green goblin
mask I
would never let anybody play rem only I play rem how How
dare you suggest me to play anything else?
How dare you?
I wish you can have that.
You can...
What if...
I wish you could have two rems.
All right.
Rem only.
Rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, rem,
rem, rem, rem, rem, rem, One, one, one, one, one, one, one,
one, one, one.
Yeah, you can't really do anything when you're in here.
I mean, can you actually explore while you're in, while
you're queued up?
Oh, you can.
Wait, we can.
Wait, we can explore New York City.
Yet we are.
Let's look at our tunnels properly.
Okay.
Okay, this is how I always do my tunnels.
I just go over here.
Because I don't know any other holes.
This is the only hole I know.
And then I guess...
And I just go through here.
I just need to know where...
I keep forgetting where the other holes are.
I keep forgetting where they lead to.
Where do these holes lead?
Okay, exit.
Which one is this?
I'm just gonna forget it anyway.
Okay.
subway the other subway all right and then I'm gonna forget
it but I'm gonna try to pretend I know what I'm doing okay
here and then this exit is okay it's this side okay all
right and then this side this side where is this exit this
side is where the fuck is always This one!
Okay.
Yep, I meant outside.
I don't know where the outside tunnel is.
Like, how to go in from the other tunnels.
You know what I mean?
Like, I keep...
Like, it's so time that I don't remember where the holes
are.
Okay, this exit.
Where does this go?
Because, like, you know, I always forget where these holes
are from the outside.
The fuck is...
Oh, the subway has...
Oh, Rem?
Rem?
Am I...
Where am I?
I'm fucking rat rank.
Of course.
Of course I'm rat rank.
Of course I am.
I am.
I'm home.
Welcome to the mines.
The rat rank for him.
Better than hashtag not.
Don't say that it's gonna happen don't say that it's gonna
happen to me and you know it you know it's gonna happen to
me after eight games after eight games it's gonna happen I'm
gonna place it oh yeah where is everyone else I don't have
time to get water at this point to get refill my water
taking a while to load in
I'm gonna get water I don't know if this guy's even connect
ah yippee okay oh I'm with mowing krill but a rat rank
mowing krill that's a little concerning
little worried.
A rat ranked Moe and Grill.
If you can't get above rat rank when you're playing Moe and
Grill, then then I don't think there's any hope for you
anymore.
This is probably less stressful than a shift at the diner.
Rats.
We are in the rat.
Alright.
I have friends.
Don't say that.
Any rat, rat, moan, creole players?
I think...
I'm sorry.
But I think...
I think it might be over for us.
Why do I need this army hex?
I'm not hearing somebody over.
Oh my god, I get the fruit fly!
Oh my god!
A fucking course I get fruit fly.
A fucking course.
My rank game has fruit fly man in here.
Of course he's here.
Alright.
I can buy.
There you go.
I'm gonna get stupid fruit fly.
The moment I took him off of my bads list.
She shows up.
Because of course.
Get him!
Wait, where is he?
Oh my.
Proof fucking flat.
Thank you.
God damn proof flat.
Fucker.
Okay.
God damn proof flat.
At least these guys can't aim.
You know, I'll take that.
Thank God in this Elo.
Like, I'll take that.
Thank God.
Oh,
my God.
There you go.
Alright, I already used up all my jumps.
Don't let him explode.
on me, I swear to God.
Alright, here we go.
Maybe I should heal.
I'm gonna go heal.
I believe my Mo and Crele.
He has 9,000 HP.
I would be dead in any other Elo.
Thank God for rat rank.
Thank fucking God these guys can't fucking aim.
Even me, and apparently also I can't aim as well.
Alright.
Holy shit.
Alright, that's fine.
I have Tagalog now.
So I need more help, but I can heal at least.
I can be more aggressive.
Oh, whatever.
How does he dodge?
that wait moan krill don't worry moan krill
holy shit he's so low he's actually one go moan krill surf
he's so low he's actually so low i'm so sad we almost killed
him bro we almost got it
had it bro
all right it's five did my fucking oh my god that's where he
went
wait I didn't realize he went to the shop how is that that
where my help how did my helper go all the way there how did
he get there it was so far
I was like, how did he get there?
It's five.
All right.
Holy shit, he's going straight in it.
All right, it's five.
They should ride some things.
All right, go back in.
My finalist is shooting him.
Oh my god.
He's solo.
He's actually solo.
Go for her!
Where is she?
Oh my god.
No, she went right.
I'm so sad.
We were so close.
Is he gonna be five?
Because yeah, Marisa's gonna be five.
right because I need to do this I'm so sad we were so close
I'm healing him for a little bit though yeah we have moon
moon power
Maurice oh my god I didn't realize you want to go
Maurice now you back out nice
for one time I am!
Ah!
All right, we're full now.
He's got it.
And no more knows you're saving.
I see Billy.
Holy shit, now he went in.
He was aggressive when I don't want him to be aggressive.
She shall temper your spirit forces.
Oh, what the most?
stealing we're actually with the mo okay i can steal now
thank you really fine let's hope our mo and krill doesn't
die okay all right it's fine i'm here now
i should go by the curiosity shoppy all right i think i got
their doubles actually i don't i don't got their doubles But
I got some I got others though Oh, they know they they got
rid of my thing I don't got their doubles
But I can get rid of this one though.
I'm gonna steal their other doubles
Keep trying to steal it
What if I tried to steal it again?
The mythical place of rat rank.
I keep trying to steal it.
Wait, I can...
Wait, he doesn't...
He already stole it.
Is someone's birthday?
Oh, I'll give you a happy birthday soon!
Oh, I thought that would hit him.
Not gonna lie.
I can grab this right now, actually.
Oh my god.
It was worth it, honestly.
Oh my god, are you serious?
Why did you all when I all did?
Mo!
I said, why did you all?
It's fine.
It's okay.
This motherfucker.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Ow.
I'm so sad.
all right let's see if i can grab the doubles again i'm
pretty sure they like stopped it before i could grab it so
i'm gonna try again
i see billy oh my god i thought i saw something i thought he
was gonna fucking kill me did he actually get it oh wait
what it's gone i'm gonna help them i guess
oh they're never mind
holy shit well we tried we really did try
we tried this truly is rat rank yeah i was gonna say why did
he not reset it well i need him to go over here so i can all
right anyway Our blue guardian is still fine.
Don't be a jerk.
Alright.
Oh, we got yellow at least.
Alright, I'm going to blue.
Wait, we can get Walker.
Wait, there's no way.
How is this Walker ready almost dead?
What?
I mean, I'll take it.
The Archmothers favor.
Oh, sure.
Ah, no.
Heading to Broadway.
We take those.
Oh, no, Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo.
Mo, there's the Guardian, Mo!
Oh, I almost got it.
Whoops.
This Mo...
Oh, okay.
This...
I mean, okay.
Rats.
We are the rats!
Would be fucked up if I unpause it.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna click it.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna click it.
Do it?
Do I do it?
Do I... Do I...
Everyone won't...
Why can't anyone else do it?
It's tradition.
Do it.
I'm going to do it.
Oh, Bubba, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Joki.
Thank you for all the laughs.
Today's my birthday.
You get happy birthday.
Of course.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Bubba.
Yeah!
Happy if they don't know.
They won't know.
Oh, man.
Who could have done that?
Oh
my god, who could have done that?
So rude!
Okay.
I'm gonna kill everybody, pull up real quick.
Thanks.
Alright.
That's so rude.
Whoever that was that that unpaused.
You're right, they got it anyway.
That's a man.
You're so right, guys.
came back in time so i didn't you know i didn't grief
anybody okay now i'll do tunnels i do tunnels now tunnel
tunnel tunnel where am i in wait what tunnel am i in tunnels
all right i assume the
i know it's pretty fucked up whoever it was that i see the
enemy
Whoever that was, that unpaused.
How dare they?
Yeah, I should help our victor.
Wait.
I should help our...
Wait, they're fine.
They don't need help.
Wait, this guy live?
Oh.
I am helpful.
Alright, I should be able to spend money now.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I'll go back soon.
Alright.
I'll come back now.
Oh, blue.
It'll be fine.
Our guardian will not be fine.
Our guardian is not fine.
Alright, that is not good.
Alright, I'm going to give some extra heals real quick.
There we go.
We still have our blue.
Our blue is still alive.
Okay.
Oh, I got it.
I still got the assist.
Let's go.
A sack's a sack.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to.
Everything's fine.
Easy stack.
Dude, get to the victor.
Get to the victor.
There we go.
We got, we got to kill.
We got to kill.
He said my turn and I'm scared.
Bitch.
Oh, I don't think I can do...
I think she's dead.
Oh, wait, unless...
They're five.
Holy shit, I'm low and crill.
Alright, that's five.
I hope...
Little drifter, little drifter...
Oh, hey, nice.
We're five.
Little drifter, go.
Little drifter means I go.
I believe in...
Oh wait, I don't have enough money.
I'm gonna go this way for money.
My blind shot.
Oh, yeah, here I am.
I'm helpful.
I'm gonna go grab this.
Who's dead?
Not our team.
Good.
I'm coming over.
I know the tunnels!
It's right here.
It was not here.
This was not the tunnels I was looking for.
What tunnel am I in?
What tunnel am I in right now?
I don't know what tunnel...
Oh!
This way!
I should never go out of the tunnels.
I should never farm outside of my usual tunnels, because I
don't know.
I always get lost.
Mine.
Wait, is he going for our mowing crit?
What is he doing?
No.
We didn't get it.
Aw, they took it.
They took them in.
Oh, Rift.
Rift time.
I'll go help Rift.
Death slam is good to go.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, Mokrit.
Live!
The little rem that could is here!
Nice.
Don't worry, I'm here.
I'm here.
We got this.
Where's my mowing krill?
Mow?
Mowing krill?
Here we go.
For the cause!
I did it for the team!
Oh my god!
I'm pulling the team!
My sacrifice is not in vain.
It was worth it.
Would nobody think of the poor little rem fighting for his
life while Snake was trying to eat her?
But no one think of the poor little rim.
I'm on a fucking sealer secret shop.
Fuck them.
Stealing a secret shop.
I fucked up.
Okay, that was a troll.
Now, I didn't think they would save me.
steal their tunnels no not the twifta the green but green is
good
a twifta okay i won't greet anymore i lie i say as i lie to
myself i
okay i'm coming over
Okay, I'm heading over.
Let's go to Broadway.
Okay, here we go.
Let's go, sir.
Where are they?
Are they in here?
Okay, I killed a drift off.
We did it!
Okay.
All right.
We got Dwyfta.
Dwyfta down.
All right.
Do you do mid?
Oh, at mid?
Oh, at mid time.
We, it's one.
We're doing mid?
What?
Okay, it's one.
Okay, I don't think we should have done, we should be doing
mid.
Like, look at our death.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know about this mid idea.
I don't have, I don't have sleep, guys.
I guess I'll be here.
Oh, they're coming.
Oh, okay, mid is fine.
Mid is good.
Headed to yellow.
Mid was good.
Let's push green.
We should be pushing green.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, our lash got that.
Come on, green.
I thought we were gonna die, not gonna lie.
Okay,
my rem went to the shop instead.
My rem went to the shop.
My little guy went to the shop instead.
My little guy went to the shop.
Headed to green.
I thought he was...
two more.
I can grab this maybe.
Oh no, he actually went to this.
Oh my god.
My lash at, my ash at It actually ran away.
Bro, I left you.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Lash really said, fuck you.
I thought he was coming back for me.
Black.
I only over-send this because I saw the lash behind me.
So I thought I could tag along to him, but then he's like, I
didn't, he's just as stupid as me.
That doesn't come back for us.
Okay, all right, no more.
Okay, I know I said no more overstanding.
Now I will not overextend.
Now I won't overextend, guys.
This is when it stops.
After I realized I do not have...
the teammates in rat rank everyone else is awesome little
rat they're all rats apparently okay no more i'm not
overextending for that mowing krill like he he let him die
we we let him die i'm not i'm not helping i know what
happened to me last step At best, I'll throw this in.
There we go.
Again?
Oh my god.
I didn't think he was going to die so fast.
That was my bad, I guess.
That was my bad for thinking that.
Why did you die?
There was no reason to die there
All right, it's fine
It's fine All right I think we can Really, you want to keep
push Alright, whatever, let's go Let's go And grab that
shrine And then this shrine too Oh shit, wait, yellow.
Let's go yellow.
Did he die too?
Okay, he died.
Oh no.
Twifta.
Twifta!
I tried!
Oh, the situation I was in!
Hey, but all that money though.
Alright, I can buy these.
At least I have disarming hex now.
I see the enemy.
I'm coming over.
Okay.
Mina, Mina,
Mina, Dwyfta, Dwyfta's here, Dwyfta.
There's no way.
Oh my god, picture my hero!
My fucking hero, Victor, you got this.
He's literally one.
Victor shares his pain.
I'm doing this.
Oh, nice.
Free stack, free stack.
Oh, my God.
Don't want to be here.
Get him.
He's asleep.
Get him!
Yes!
We go, we go, we rush.
Just finish it, just finish it!
Let's push yellow.
Yellow!
Just fucking go whatever is closest!
Guys, I would love some health right now.
My little peace shooter can't do much.
Okay.
There we go.
That's my little pea shooter gun!
Alright.
Oh man, I'll take it.
Get over here.
Alright.
Alright, one more.
Alright, here everybody!
Where am I?
Hi!
Holy shit, I can't see anything.
Guys, I'm so scared.
I am so scared right now.
Please, please let me live.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Alright.
What?
Mid again?
Wait, mid?
I didn't realize you had old.
Mid again!
There, here I go!
Here I go!
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, I stay here.
Just in case.
Alright, back at it again.
I have so much money.
I go to a secret shop.
There you go.
Round two Where are you going good?
Let's go my little guy bought me a little gift guys
Oh, yeah, he's dead
That's it.
My first melee.
Alright, we're back.
We're back at it again.
I don't know.
I got somebody.
Oh, everybody's full HP.
Yeah!
Rat rake!
Rake!
Yeah!
Rat rake!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah!
Rats!
We are the rats!
Rat rink!
Yippee!
I got 19 issues.
I got, hey, more damage than, hey, not too bad.
Not too shabby.
Not...
I will say not too shabby.
not nine at least not 9.6k damage yippee we won our we won
our game let's go I think I did alright I think I did other
than the fact that I overextended those two talents because
I trusted I believed in my team and clearly you should never
believe in your team look at that at least I know I belong
at least I know I'm a round rat rink.
Hey.
No.
All right.
Wow.
Yes.
Thank you.
I'm going to call it here.
It's been fun.
Oh, my gosh.
It's been six hours.
We've been, we've been ratting it out for six hours.
These games, like, I haven't, I feel like I haven't even
played that many games.
But, oh my, the games take so little.
God.
I only like this game if I'm Rem.
I hate this game if I'm any other character.
Even when I'm losing, at least I'm...
If I'm on Rem, I'm happy.
But if I'm on any other character, I fucking hate this game.
Like, this game is miserable if I'm on any other character.
Yeah.
But I hope you guys had fun watching.
Even though I'm not, like, you know, I'm not a really great
player.
I'm rat rank.
I think I had fun playing.
And I hope you guys had fun watching me today.
And I think, you know, I feel like I improved a lot.
You know, guys.
Like, you're watching the journey from the first REM stream
to this stream.
I think I had like a little character arc, you know.
I improved a lot today.
Yeah.
Thank you guys.
I'm glad you're enjoying the stream.
over the couple of uh over the over the week yeah i'm
improving guys yeah wow wow wow i'm improving wow wow wow
wow wow and guys i'm gonna call it here as always everybody
say hydrated posture check get up and move around get that
blood flowing and if you stand up for me head to bed cause
you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody me
thank you thank you your inner crow calls at you dover
because i know i know i'm like but i could be even further
up as a little chud all right do you get the super chat
thank you thank you for the nice stream thank you for
watching i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye